Oh Shit.
The Joe Rogan experience.
It's sexy too.
Cause it's English.
Yeah.
Who Do you know that person?
No,
she's not even real.
So robot it is,
but I just think of her as something dirty bitch and England.
Yeah.
Weird cat to work.
Yay me crooked feet.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Nice feet.
She's hot.
She is.
She's a big are teeth though.
I don't mind it.
A little space here and there.
I met you.
It works.
It's fine.
It's the discoloration.
I can,
I'm not down with gray yet.
Not even great.
But you know how sometimes they have like six different colors?
Yeah.
Or like bottle rot.
When did you,
when did you stop sucking on your Banky Hooker,
ladies and gentlemen.
Bobby Lee has joined us.
Yes.
Finally,
I mean,
your army.
You have an army out there,
dude,
not mine,
man.
Well,
they have their own,
but they forget of army.
Uh,
before we get started,
we have two business.
Uh,
we are,
uh,
sponsored by the flashlight.
Uh,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com or if you go to Joe rogan.net,
there's a link for the fleshlight.
Click on it and enter in a code name.
Rogan get 15% off.
I have used one of those.
I haven't won.
The thing is,
is those beads,
have you seen the blue one?
The beads Avatar One?
No,
it looks like a flashlight.
Right?
Right.
And you stick the thing inside it,
right?
If the one,
yeah,
that one I have that.
I have these little beads,
beads that you turn on.
You stick your balls in it.
I know you used to get,
I know,
but there's these beads on mine that you put in and it vibrates.
It's three beats and goes on the side.
If you open that up and put beets inside.
But the real only last five minutes.
Right.
And I take 10 minutes to do it.
Oh,
so last five minutes.
You just holding your breath.
No,
I know.
I have a whole system in the side.
I have all these batteries.
But why don't you just have to,
and then you have two flashlights and so you have one on standby.
You could cleaning them is a half an hour thing.
A half an hour.
What are you going to brush?
I use hot oil.
Use Hot oil to clean them?
No,
no,
no.
From the golf.
No,
I I um,
I microwave oil for five seconds and they get it warm.
You can't do it too hot.
I did it once in a scalded Mike South eyes.
Yeah.
But Burns.
But um,
yeah,
you put the oil in it,
right?
Yeah.
And then you put the beads in it.
It vibrate.
It's still,
it's so good.
It's like go up to an android and then,
which is a FNTC during dream and then,
um,
but at the beads run off,
run out of energy.
So only five minutes for these whack ass beats.
Yeah.
And brand new.
You'd have to put three of those flat.
What do you got?
The watch batteries.
A little tiny ones.
You Watch my 40 bucks a pop when you're doing that.
Wow.
Where do you get these beats?
I've never even heard of these beads that opened that up.
I bet you if there's beats slots.
No.
Yes.
You take the share.
You're not talking about a competitor.
That's it now.
No.
You tell him what the are my mind.
I have three slots here.
Oh,
you're so yours is designed for it specific.
It is a flashlight,
a flashlight.
But it's a different,
it's a different way.
You stick in there and go,
oh,
maybe you've got a vibrator model or something.
Or vibrate.
Do have the vibrator models.
I remember seeing that.
Yeah,
I have that one.
But it's the same.
It looks exactly,
but you know,
this is a controversial thing,
man.
I do a whole series of,
uh,
do a whole bit about it.
I'm onstage,
but this really is controversy because people don't want,
it didn't want me getting sponsored by a fake vagina.
Like there's somehow or another,
it's like bad for your reputation.
Does it really take you 10 minutes to come?
Yeah,
because that now what do you have regular sex is to take you 10 minutes.
It takes you longer and I see something I want to,
can I see you?
I'm sure I'm being very specific on my point.
The thing is is that I need the interview.
Okay.
You know the interview,
the interview,
the interview with a girl so far around where it,
so where are you from?
Where you from?
I'm from Ohio.
You know how many,
how much point have you done?
Not that much.
This is my second time.
Well first I need to sense a little fear in her voice.
Right.
And then check it out.
You know,
the first time when they get the first timers,
when the penis goes into the vagina,
I have to look at their eyes in the realize they have to question their
decision.
How you get excited.
You know,
how like when the penis goes in the ethical mom,
you associate that with any past sexual experiences where you see the look in
the girls.
I was just like,
what the fuck is Bobby Lee doing inside me?
And then you get excited,
like tricked him again.
Josie,
I think what it is this,
I think that I am my penis.
It's not even an ethnic thing,
but my penis is abnormally small.
I don't care about it because you know what,
I'm rapping house.
It's just small egg thumb.
No.
Yeah,
it's thick.
It's thicker than that.
All right.
But the thing is is that,
and girls,
you know,
they liked my bubbly personality.
I'm like a dream weaver.
You know what I mean?
And you know what I mean?
You're fun.
You're fun to be around.
You bring a party.
Yeah.
And so then all of a sudden there's parties fucking your mouth.
You're like,
hey,
yeah.
And,
and when I'm out with the girl,
I look in their eyes and it's,
I've never had the sensation of like them going,
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Like it's too big.
You know what I mean?
I have a friend of mine who had that same problem.
And so what he started doing was getting,
uh,
he got a strap on,
he got this crazy thing that covers his dick and I was like,
his Dick would go on and then this like big fake Dick would go over his dick.
Oh,
we were talking to him about it.
We're like,
well what's up?
Like why do you,
why do you,
what are you doing that for?
He goes,
cause just once I want to see a girl,
like I have a hard time taking it.
Yes.
They can always take it so easy.
Yeah.
Never hurting now.
Sorry.
You really big into anal.
No,
I don't do that.
You think you would be though,
cause that most girls that even with your small Dick wouldn't know because me if
for me it's like I want them to have pleasure to,
for some girls,
like it likes anal with better than regular sex.
She just wants anal all the time.
Girls.
And they're called broken.
Yeah.
And those are the ones who are also light your house on fire,
by the way.
I always have this.
I also imagine if you do an anal and you don't have a condom on that the,
the,
the
poop goes into the whole my whole thoughts and I don't want,
I don't need that in my life.
We talked about a terrible scene.
Did we talk about that on the podcast?
The,
the,
uh,
the naughty show thing.
Yeah,
we did it and I saw snakes are actually cool.
If you're at a bar when you shut up,
what's a pip stop when you pass or anal sex,
then we will come down.
No,
I don't know.
I don't need that in my life.
You should try it.
And he's just talking.
He's a sense,
he's been silly.
He does this all the time.
You can't take him.
See,
you've never had a poop snake poop smell though.
Now with this worse,
Ooh,
there's a girl has sex with a long time ago,
back when I was 21,
I lost my boner because I was banging her style and I saw poop around her
butthole.
I realized that she didn't really wiped that good.
And then I started smelling it because the funk of the sax and the sweat.
Yeah,
my wet nap.
Do you ever do that?
My,
but yeah,
I went,
not my baby.
Flush those out by the way,
that you cannot flush those.
You gotta.
You gotta wipe yourself first and then you've got to get the baby wipes and then
you've got to throw the baby wipes away,
which is kind of gross because you got a flood.
Well if you live in an apartment,
go flush away.
If you live in a house,
eventually they're going to get clogged up and you gonna have to have a group of
dudes come in your backyard and fine.
This pipe stuffed full of your shit.
Me Know Bro.
I'm,
I'm used flushable wipes.
The flexible ones,
they don't,
that's the thing.
They pretend they do.
They don't really,
they become like Goo,
they don't dissolve toilet paper and they get tied up on things.
Like if you have,
like in my area we have issues with,
cause we're kind of rural,
we have issues with trees growing into your pipes.
You know,
it's an issue like will like there's so many trees out here,
the trees will like grow through like a crack in the pipe and one of them became
like a Goddamn tree.
I mean I posted pictures of it on Twitter.
It's so ridiculous.
Nobody even fucking believes it.
I was,
my toilet was clogged.
I couldn't figure out what was going on with it.
So I had these plumbers come out,
they pulled a fucking eight foot tree out of my,
out of my toilet.
Oh my God.
Maybe not eight foot.
How big was it?
At least five feet.
Yeah,
like five feet long.
It was like,
it was like you're high.
It looked like a mumble shit.
It looked like a muppet,
like a swamp thing.
Like some sort of an animal,
like a,
like somebody flushed.
Uh,
some,
some would rat some,
but we are you worried that if they opened up the pipe,
they're stuffed with wet naps,
but can't you just say it's my children's?
No,
it's mine.
I would give up the fucking own it.
I'm not gonna throw out to the bar.
That's ridiculous.
You're not supposed to be diaper wipes.
You definitely don't flush.
Cause they're really thick and course.
I mean not course,
but a strong that they would not break up.
Definitely.
But the flushable baby wipes,
those bitches don't break our beat it.
The guy told me no,
they say they break up.
People say he goes,
I pulled them out of peoples' pipes all the time.
So they had to like dig a hole,
but it was really the issue more or less was that there was a,
uh,
there was walking part of the area,
not as bad as the one that was in the toilet.
The one that was in the toilet was fucking ridiculous.
I'll find it and I'll repost that shit on Twitter because it's just so silly.
It doesn't even make sense.
It's just,
it's so silly.
It really,
it didn't look real.
Like I couldn't believe it.
And
that was after I moved to Colorado,
so I left the house for a couple of months and nobody was,
nobody was flushing.
Yeah.
I just wish I,
I can,
like masturbating lasted longer for me because it,
to me,
it's just like,
I seriously have to focus on slowing it down.
Oh,
what are you trying to do?
Their felon?
No,
that's with sex and everything.
I just,
I just masturbation though.
Isn't that like just trying to get it over with,
but I like to enjoy it,
you know?
I mean,
it feels good when you're doing it right.
So why not have it go for like 10 minutes?
Yeah.
Well the other day I was in,
I wasn't,
when I was in New York,
I tried to masturbate to porn on the Internet.
I couldn't finish.
Right.
So then like I asked for about an hour,
I finished half hard.
And you always feel like a failure because it's like,
it didn't see my orgasm was like 50% you know what I mean?
And it just sat there with like,
you know my hand like with this marshmallow in my hand,
you know what I mean?
Just sitting there naked,
sweating.
You're not going,
I failed at that.
I couldn't even finish that off.
Wow.
I do feel you,
me and Bobby were talking about how when we stay at hotels,
we hate when the maid comes down.
Come in my room,
don't ever come to my room.
And I didn't tell you that.
But I did Spiderman at the last hotel we were at and it hit Musta hit the lamp
because it starts smoking.
What are you talking about?
Where I do spider man.
And a hotel where I throw Brian,
people listening.
Well,
we've talked about Spiderman,
the no worries.
No one listens to every,
I don't know what the fuck you're saying.
And I masturbate masturbation hotels.
I have just,
I just,
I'm like,
fuck this,
I'm in this hotel and I'd just like throw the sperm at the wallet.
Spiderman.
Right.
Throw it across the room.
And it still connects to your wrist?
No,
no.
It doesn't connect to the room now.
No,
but it just so disrespectful because some poor Mexican lady has to clean up.
So just,
I'm so mad,
rude,
clear.
They don't clean.
It dries and then flakes and you don't know what it is.
They think it's either mucus or you're mean or a load or the load.
I can't even see where it goes.
And once I hit a a picture frame and I was like,
oh,
I better clean that.
So disrespectful.
Once you hit a picture,
like a picture on the wall.
Yeah,
I could go issue
masturbate and try to enjoy yourself when I masturbate.
It's for maintenance to get it over with don joy and moving on even better a
towel and she'll definitely touch the towels.
The problem with,
uh,
with getting into masturbating and zen you like,
you're like already had that joke about like having a bunch of windows open,
trying to figure out what to jerk off to.
You can get weird and obsessed.
You can get kinda get a little caught up in it.
There's some dudes who,
you know,
they get so caught up in porn.
It becomes like a legit addiction where like they'll have a conversation with
someone and they just can't wait to get,
go into their computer real quick and just look at,
look at porn videos I have to do.
I could pay for my pawn now.
Really?
I can't do grainy.
It has to be high def.
Oh really?
You got to be able to see the freckles.
You're the last guy,
the last guy buying porn.
Yeah,
I really am.
I need to ask about a business that just got gutted.
I know.
I mean that used to be a multimillionaire business.
I mean,
there was some billion dollar business,
right?
There was so many people in my that were,
uh,
the porn producers maybe driving around in Ferrari's living the good life.
And I believe,
look at this wild ass rebel just filming fucking and making $1 billion.
It's crazy.
You know,
it's kind of a weird thing.
You know the,
it'd be like a curiosity in the community.
You know,
like all these mommy's would look at them.
That's the porn guy that's worth of porn guy leaves the porn guy.
But now those guys are making shit that that's done.
Done son Sia.
If you're lucky,
you can get by now and if you're lucky you get Charlie sheen.
Well look at this hookers.
These hookers can't stop talking about Charlie Sheen.
It just there doing interviews or heard someone on stern this morning.
There's fucking good morning America interviewed one of the girls that Fuck
Charlie Sheen.
Way to go.
Good Morning America.
You whores,
congratulations.
You are now us magazine and he allows you in his house,
gives you we cocaine course you get to watch,
you know,
movies that haven't even come out yet on DVD that you want to watch.
True Grit that's out in the theaters.
But I have it right there doing cool to watch avatar two.
I've got a rough cut David and made that thing.
Get her mean and then the disrespect him by,
you know,
ratting them out course.
Yeah,
they're not as friends.
Could you imagine if that was your friend?
A massive,
a dude came over your house.
Forget about sex just to dude came over your house and have,
you know,
hey,
we all watched a fucking TV at Bobby Lee's house.
He got nutty,
he takes his pants off,
runs with and all a sudden this dude is on,
you know,
the radio on Monday and he's telling the whole story about what he did hanging
out at your house when you got crazy.
Blake,
fuck is this guy.
That guy will never hang out at my house again.
This idiot.
Imagine how shit can you imagine being that little kid from two and a half men.
How much tail Charlie?
Thursdays way.
Hey,
I got this daughter,
this girl I fuck 12 shuttle.
Yeah,
and I old now.
It also,
that kid is so mad.
Probably because the shell k get canceled.
All right.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They could all lose it.
1 million.
They're,
they're trying to say all sorts of shit.
Like,
Oh,
it was appendix Burger.
He had a hernia.
That kids,
well,
they all are,
it's the biggest show on television.
And by the way,
this is only helping it.
Yeah,
helping it.
People are not going to stop.
Charlie Sheen is a fucking,
for whatever reason,
man,
he's grandfathered in.
All right.
Johnny shitting ain't going nowhere.
He could do coke all day.
He could bang hookers.
He could threaten his wife with a knife.
It doesn't matter.
It's fucking smiling on camera on Monday.
I like how the La Police won't even do any like investigations to these alleged
cocaine.
A briefcase charges.
I was like,
wait a second.
If someone has a briefcase of cocaine,
maybe you should find out what the fuck.
No,
no,
no.
That was the Ohio they would,
first of all,
it's all,
it's all hearsay.
Okay.
You can't take this hookers word for it.
Or pornstar whoever's saying,
first of all,
there's that.
And then second of all,
what are you going to do?
You're going to question him about whether or not he had cocaine for real and
he's going to say no,
and then he's going to say,
where's your evidence?
Where's this from?
And then the evidence is just some girl talking about it.
Unless I grow once.
So like go in and talk to the government.
And what does she know?
She knows a guy came over with cocaine.
You were doing cocaine,
so you were doing something illegal to yeah,
we'll start off.
Just Charlie pay you to fuck.
That's prostitution.
Um,
can I call my lawyer?
Come on,
man.
He was,
he has this awesome article on yesterday.
We're like Charlie Sheen's old friend or publicist or something like that.
Used to hang in his life and get in a lot of trouble with them and then he'd,
I kind of disappeared for a few years.
Well lately he's been hanging out with this guy again.
So they took up,
they found him the other day while he's been hanging out with,
yeah.
Charlie's been hanging out with this guy again recently and so they found him
yesterday,
like walking on the street somewhere in sunset or something and uh,
he had an enjoy coke shirt on and they're like,
Huh,
interesting.
Oh my gosh,
this is a testimonial.
What a great actor Charlie Sheen is.
Because just listen to my theory that you've listened to my theory.
Okay.
When you act,
you have to,
some actors get acting coaches,
right?
They get the script right.
They memorize their lines.
They have to go to table reason rehearsals.
This student just shows up,
you know what I mean?
Just after the two night bender,
right.
Once you've been on a sitcom for that long,
it becomes very easily.
Yeah.
News radio,
the last couple seasons was super easy news radio,
we were working three days a week.
It was so easy.
Yeah.
And you know,
and we would get like a script and then we'd fuck around with it for a couple of
days and then Friday a sweatshop and no one wants to.
US worked hard.
And you guys had like weird guidance man.
We had nine Mexicans Watch those two dudes that were running it.
Man,
those guys odd tastes.
It was the weirdest show I've ever hosted at once.
And that's one of the Times I knew you before that though,
right?
Yeah,
I,
that's where I'm at.
Barton County and a I hosted at once and I remember like talking to them about
my,
like they wanted me to do a monologue and you know,
so I'm like,
all right,
well I'll talk about this and I'll talk about that.
And like,
you know,
all right.
But it was just,
it was a real awkward,
I was like,
how the fuck did these guys get to be running some sort of a sketch show?
And it was the weirdest sketch show ever.
And not only that,
it's like no one,
there was no like id like people could just walk in,
you know?
I mean,
I just had people like walk and go,
Hey,
like in my hallway,
what am I dressing rose?
Right.
Hey Man,
what's up?
Who are you?
Oh,
I didn't know.
Watching the show.
How are you back here?
How'd they get back there?
I don't know if there was like no security.
I don't know.
I never met a security guard.
No security?
No.
It was on Highland and Santa Monica.
You know that one.
It seemed like a factory was weird.
Weird.
Yeah.
It didn't seem like a regular show.
And then we would have big stuff sometimes.
Like Jackie Chan did.
It was like,
what are you doing here?
You're legitimate.
You're an international superstar.
And went on forever too.
Yeah.
And I behaved like a fucking asshole too.
Then I pooped in.
I pooped in London.
Brown skis.
Uh,
um,
office floor floor.
I was so mad at her.
Why are you mad at her?
Because she just stayed to see view really worn.
Dubroski did?
Nope.
She'd passed away.
I know.
I knew her from back in Boston when she was on a comedy team.
She saved my life.
Really?
I love learning and their shit on her floor because you love me.
It was,
it was as a joke and it was too raw actors writing in there.
Right.
I can Nicole Parker,
we're riding and Iko stick this Tom's and your asshole just for tums.
I stuck it in my butthole and then my butthole started foaming and then they
both laughing like really loud.
And then I shopped the Tom's out of my butthole and then a piece of poo came up
after that.
Right.
It was a huge lab.
And then Lauren Port Lauren,
you know,
walks in and she sees a toms that's foaming and a piece of poop on the floor and
I had to clean it up.
So it's stuff like that,
you know what I mean?
Because when no one watches it and we had free range is to act just as crazy as
why was it so bad?
What was bad?
Just because there was no real boss.
Right.
And also what happened was Fox didn't own it.
The Warner Brothers did.
Right.
And it's still wonder brothers didn't care about it.
Fox didn't care about it and we just end.
No one watched it and I don't know how it stayed on,
but every year they would go,
yeah,
you're going to come back.
I go,
really?
You know,
I mean,
you and I used to have these conversations in the back of the container store
where you didn't know what to do.
Kind of know what to do.
I mean,
they're giving me x amount of dollars a week and I,
it's a steady job and it fucking is fucking terrible.
Terrible.
You fucking hated it.
I hated it.
I mean,
if five of them,
when you'd show up,
no one's there,
you would have this look on your face,
man.
Sometimes you would have this look in your face where you just like,
you didn't know what to do and cried a lot.
You fucking hide cried so much.
I'll let Joe.
So at five in the morning,
I mean,
when you'd show up for work,
five o'clock call,
you should have a hook.
There's no one there,
no one.
Yeah.
And then at five 40 call,
people started showing up.
I go,
why did you call me?
Who runs this thing?
You know,
call times are always brewed or I hate it.
I hate when they get you in early.
Just in lies.
They lie,
they lie.
They're liars.
To show up at five and then you shoot at eight at night.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Because,
well first of all,
because comedians are responsible.
You have to take that into account.
You are.
I am.
Brian is an important story.
Joey d is the most irresponsible person I've ever met in my fucking life.
You are our,
he's fairly responsible,
but even the hamburger responsible,
pretty nuts.
Another time I got in trouble,
they get the,
they had sued me.
One of the actors to try to sue me really shows it was the first day of work,
right.
She finally gets on a sketch show,
right,
and she later became,
she kind of,
she's on mad men and she was on the cover of playboy,
but when she,
what's her name?
Her name is Christa Flanagan.
Hold on.
We're going to look up to a playboy.
Put that on Chris with a C or C r I.
S.
T.
A.
One of my best friends in the whole world.
She is.
Yeah,
she is.
How do you spell her last name?
Flanagan.
F.
L.
A.
N.
You guys,
you have a very weird friendships.
Why?
Cause you know you're friends with somebody.
People on their floor.
You forget somebody who get sued.
But no,
no,
she was in playboy,
but Flanagan didn't know me.
Hurts a first day of work.
Five in the morning.
She shows up and we had rehearsals in the actors rehearsal hall and she's
sitting on the couch.
I had no idea who she was.
She was eating yogurt.
Okay.
So I was so early,
I'm delirious.
I had like 30 minutes of sleep.
I walked up to her,
I grabbed the back of her head and he farther near her mouth was using yogurt.
Right.
She starts crying until she started crying.
So then Ron Peterson,
who you know who Ron Peterson is,
right?
No,
the guy that went out with Natasha,
Laura,
you know that whole thing.
I don't know how it goes.
You know what?
The whole controversy with Ari,
I know there was a controversial Natasha left with the mad TV.
Good.
Ron Peterson
is the guy.
Okay,
well that's very pretty her mouth.
Yup.
You're a confident man.
What made you so confident?
That part and it's pretty girls face.
She's Oh,
fart in her mouth.
So then Ron Peterson physically attack me.
Mike McDonald in the show while you farted are but no after that because she
started crying.
Right.
So you farted in her mouth and her mouth with yogurt.
Okay.
She was eating.
He's eating.
You come by,
you fart in her mouth when you grabbed your butt,
touch your face.
No,
I had my jeans on full that you can go through two layers of underwear and
jeans.
That felt a strong ones like that.
You know what I mean?
A lot of push.
It doesn't go,
it doesn't go right.
Go get your jeans.
Come in contact with her skin.
Really with her lips.
Oh my God.
Why in her mouth she started crying and the chicken out.
Who attacks you?
So Ron Peterson attacks me.
Right?
What does this Ron Peterson,
he is like,
he is a Canadian comedian.
So he comes after you and Mike McDonald puts him in a headlock,
puts those Peterson punching you physically attacking.
But they'll do that to me all the time.
This is what it physically assault me.
I'm just one of those guys.
And then,
you know,
but um,
so then two days later,
and you know what my manager Abby,
right?
I mean we'd sit there in front of like the Mad TV lawyers and there was an
awkward moment where like the,
they have it on tape,
they call explained to me what happened,
right.
So I go,
I showed about work that again,
and I'm like,
I see this girl,
I don't know where she's eating yogurt.
And she opened her mouth anyway,
I farted in her face and her mouth.
And then there was a 15 sentence,
second awkward pause your main where people were like writing things down,
you know what I mean?
And,
and then one guy says,
wow,
right.
And I go,
you know what I mean?
And he showed up.
So then I made a deal where I bought,
I bought her a $500 gift certificate to Brooke Williams,
gave a tour the next couple of days and I wrote her into it like a popular
sketch that I did and everything was fine.
It became very good friends foreign in my mouth and make it best buy.
Wow Man.
You know,
so unfortunate thing when people try to fuck around on sets and just have fun.
You never know right before you do something sometimes if it's too far.
But Teresa Neal had a really funny point once we're,
Patrice was talking about ims about a,
when imus got in trouble for saying something about a black,
people remember that nappy hair and he said that you can't,
you can't.
No one knows exactly what the fuck they're going to say before.
They say things like that.
And sometimes sometimes you say things that are the line,
but he's like,
that's,
but that's where all funny comes from.
If it misses or it hits,
it's still coming from the same place.
It's just trying to get a laugh and he's totally right.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
It's like people that aren't in the comedy businessman,
they don't really understand that in order to be really funny you do,
you can't really have very many.
You got to go and you know where we're from,
we're from the like,
you know,
I have so many pictures of you naked dude.
Yeah.
I have pictures you tucked I think I didn't get in the middle of the there.
I've been raped there.
I've been all kinds of things have happened growing up in the,
I have a series of pictures of you with your pants down at the comedy store from
over the years where a bought most of them.
Most of them,
he has his Dick Tucked in between his legs and his legs pinch together and your
shirt is off the the help me on a Sunday to probably a Tuesday shit,
but like,
and then you show up at a corporate workplace,
right?
Like a network show and you bring that into there and they're like,
no,
no.
Yeah.
When we were on Newsradio there was a lot of chaos for a while because they
would let us drink on the set.
So we would be done with the show and we would get fucking hammered.
We didn't get so hammered that no one knows us cause I'd never took,
shouldn't have done this with blamed it on some band.
We had a band that was,
uh,
at our,
at our studio or a on a stage,
I forgot the ban was some like very heavy metal band.
So it was perfect.
Like to blame it on them.
And um,
they uh,
they were in a scene with us.
God,
I want to say anthrax.
Was that a band?
They were right one dude that shaved head.
So,
uh,
anyway,
we were all hanging around and it was me and Dave Foley and Maura Tierney just
fucking smashed,
smashed.
And then we're hungry.
And Margo is,
we can only get in the craft service room and I'm like,
I get in that room
and I fucking a fucking taekwondo.
The door kicked the door smashed.
The doorframe really meant the fuck.
Yeah.
One kick,
I kicked open the door and um,
when inside and we fucking chowed down,
open up the fridge and then they were so pissed.
The next day they're blaming it on the band and we were like,
Yo,
that's fucked up.
That's terrible.
Those guys were fucking,
and they were gonna like stop drinking on the set because of it.
And it would get smashed.
Andy and Andy would bring these shady fucking characters over.
She used to be strange smells coming out of this fucking dressing room.
It was just a fun,
fun set man.
Yeah,
those,
the thing is you don't get real good comedy and unless you get the type of
people that don't have that many boundaries,
people that are,
that will go out there.
People that have pulled their fucking pants down.
Like all my friends that are comics,
they pull their pants down.
They do,
they do stupid shit.
They'll say,
I dare you to go do this.
Like they probably going to do if it's funny.
Yeah.
I have seen like nine 10 comics penises over the last week.
Chris Dahlia's Polly's I've seen Polly's shorts,
penis.
I'm not even lying 832 times over a lifetime.
You know what I mean?
And it's just,
I didn't ask that Christy Lee,
his penis looked like al magical.
His penis
right away is very large.
Okay.
Anyway.
Um,
but it,
but they don't,
people don't know how magical wise Matt was.
Magical as a penis.
No,
it's a pretty large too,
I guess.
No,
I don't think it is,
was not possible.
That I'll magical has a big tech.
Yeah,
it's impossible.
Really.
I don't think so because he's a Hispanic.
What are you talking about?
Hispanics don't have little ducks.
Huge moms.
How many dicks?
Mexicans.
Are you blowing?
No.
Mexicans don't blowing any Mexican.
What are you talking about?
They have a big penis or not at once,
but then at the black,
big penis,
people don't like black people,
but neither are like Irish.
Well,
Irish people,
I was supposed to be small penises.
Dick Penis,
Irish curse.
Call it the only difference between and Mexican guy in Asian guy,
except for culturally,
but physically I'm talking about is the eyes.
What?
Yeah,
the eyes.
You,
you,
if you take a Mexican guy,
you get them really high.
Right?
You fucking from Okinawa,
you're right.
But they're,
they're more,
well,
the,
our Asian really,
because what American Indians are its people that came down from the Bering
strait.
That's right.
Well,
some people have the tomato theory that mankind started in America and they went
the other way.
Hmm.
Well,
you know,
that's also possible.
We,
human beings have been around so long they've,
they've made a bunch of recent discoveries that have way,
way,
way pushed back the,
the dates of civilization.
Like we were talking about this on the podcast recently about creed.
It's an island.
It's 40 miles away from the shore and it's been that way for over 5 million
years.
And they found these stone tools that may be as old as 700,000 years old.
There are at least 100,000 years old.
So they know a hundred thousand years ago,
dudes were getting on boats and traveling 40 miles.
I mean,
that's amazing.
Shovel.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a lot of shit we don't know about people,
man.
There's a lot of shit we don't know about people,
but as far as like what we do know is that the people that were in Asia are the
same people that were North American Indians in North American.
Indians got fucked by Spaniards and they created Mexicans.
That's what it is.
That's why some Mexicans look like Indians.
They look like you could just make a fucking head dress and he'd be sitting
bull,
you know?
And what else do people don't understand is that,
you know,
Japanese and Koreans,
which I'm Korean,
right?
We have caucus away strains in our DNA because there's,
you know,
we're from Mongolia.
Right.
And they're so close to Russia,
right.
That it mixed a little bit.
Sure.
So we have that,
you know,
I mean,
so I'm kind of white.
Well,
Russia,
there's a lot of parts of Russia,
Siberia,
especially where the people look very Asian.
They looked like Bjork.
Yeah.
They're weird.
You know,
sort of an intuit look to them.
Yeah.
I'm really interested in that shit.
Yeah,
it's a trip,
man.
It's a trip when you start with really a trip about Asians that,
I mean the real trip is the stereotype that they look exactly the same and they
don't of course look exactly the same,
but I don't have to tell you that,
but,
but it is kind of weird that you have an entire group of people with narrow eyes
and the same color skin and black hair.
I mean there's like zero variation.
That's crazy that it was a billion people like that.
Yeah.
You know,
a billion plus.
Really.
I mean,
that's really amazing when you look at the,
the very minute amount of variation as opposed to European countries and even
African country.
But let me say something to you.
Okay.
It's just that,
okay,
I ran into you and Eddie wants at the Sherman Oaks Galleria,
you guys were working out at the,
at the gym there,
and I was maybe a hundred feet away from you.
Right,
right.
And there was probably 20 other agents in my area.
Right,
right.
And you from a hundred yards go,
Bobby and I turned around.
Right.
It wasn't like that too.
Like,
hey Bobby,
you know,
you yelled from like a hundred yards on.
I talked to the gym.
Yeah,
no,
it wasn't in the gym.
It was outside of the gym.
Right.
He was outside of the gym.
And so you recognize me from 100 yards away,
one amongst Asian.
So we don't look alike.
Well Bobby,
I know who you are,
but what we are friends,
we like lies are good.
I understand that.
What he's saying is,
is that we do have differences.
Sure.
You have variations in the scene theme.
The same theme is that one over again,
the same skin color.
Look,
this is not racist.
You know,
there's a,
there's a bunch of people right now.
This is not,
this is dedicated to the people that were,
we'll start fucking complaining either on a message board or on Twitter.
And you heard that,
you said about Asians are so racist.
No,
it's just an observation.
I don't find it racist.
To me it's a fascinating thing.
It's not,
it's,
there's nothing negative about it,
you know?
But what's fascinating is that,
especially like in China,
in Japan,
there are a gigantic group of people that look very,
very similar and you know,
there's not like a lot of black influence and it's not a lot of European
influential.
The fact that they were able to stay so pure for so long,
it's really quite shocking when you look at the history of the human race.
The human race had been around for,
you know,
however many hundreds and hundreds of thousands of years that they've been so
concentrated in this area that it's been,
you know,
agents breeding with Asians.
Yeah.
Almost.
Almost exclusively.
But that's the,
that's the reason why I've only did a one Asian guy.
He met a girl in my whole life.
You said guidance slipped up,
Patty,
I heard you say guy,
first girl,
guy,
girl,
Patty.
You're the power ranger in the space one when they went to space.
Yes.
Hot.
Right.
She was beautiful when I was in the bed with her.
You know how you're,
you're,
it's dark and your eyes get adjusted to the light a little bit.
The darkness,
right.
Sorry.
No,
I didn't see herself.
I saw the guy from heroes.
I saw,
I saw the lady from Grey's anatomy.
I saw my uncle Hon,
I saw Kim Jong Il.
I saw,
I saw everybody acute and after that I said,
I can't do it anymore.
Wow.
Yeah.
So the girls are always either six foot,
two blond,
Scandinavian looking lungs or like,
you know,
skinny,
Tall Mexicans that are,
you know what I mean?
But it cannot be Asians.
Wow.
I knew a girl who was Chinese and she had a thing with her dad and just Asian
guys may her throw up when she couldn't even imagine.
She was so,
so sad.
Yeah.
Poor kid.
I'm the same way if you're so exclude,
just one group,
just,
just fucking whoever was the representative.
That one group fucked up so hard.
Yeah.
But that's,
you know,
an Asian parents are really the the worst.
Really.
They are the worst because they come to this country and they just assume that
they're going to have their children here and that they're going to be doctors
and lawyers.
I mean,
that's flat out.
There's like three options,
right?
So if you come home with seeds,
you're getting an a beat.
I got beat so hard,
bro.
Well,
yeah,
just beat because I got a c on my report card.
Now.
How do your parents feel now that you're,
you're real successful as a comedian?
Do they accept them?
When they first did started doing standup?
They didn't talk to me for years,
Bro.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would say that for birthdays I go blue today,
the thanks dad.
Okay,
bye.
That's it.
Yeah.
Wow.
But I understand culturally what that's about.
Right.
And then when they saw me on the tonight show,
Leno,
like 12 years ago,
I did it right.
That was the first moment where they went,
oh,
we fuck up.
He told really fuck up.
So my dad called me emotionally and I had never seen the guy cry before and he
started crying on the phone and goes,
ah,
he showed the supported you,
but I never thought you couldn't make it.
You know what I mean?
Whoa.
It made mistake.
That's heavy,
man.
It was like the bond,
you know what I mean?
That day,
that day,
you know what I mean?
Discovered that they made a mistake the whole time.
Like me getting bad grades in school,
we get kicked out of school,
you know what I mean?
And all the behavioral problems you let out to be a comedian,
comedian that got straight A's and fucking studied all the time.
We get a lot of options.
They could have good in school,
I think.
Yeah,
I mean that's his parking problem
and that's why can I just wave a last point is the reason why that guy chill
song,
we shut up Virginia Tech because it was parents were just super suppressive as
parents.
Okay.
Only saw the kid talking to imaginary people in the park,
you know,
in,
in like a park,
right.
No,
normal parent would go dead is a mistake.
You know what I mean?
That's something wrong.
Right.
Since the kid was getting good grades in school,
they just go,
you know what,
he's getting a crate.
Right.
They never addressed the problem that he's fucking crazy.
Like my parents,
you know,
I got bad grades,
but I was always a good guy.
Like,
if I saw a homeless guy,
you know what I mean?
I would give them a dime or whatever I had in my pocket.
You're,
I mean,
I was never an evil person,
you know what I mean?
I had a good heart.
Right.
But they didn't acknowledge that part of me.
You know what I mean?
They only acknowledge that.
Is he getting good grades?
What's college is just going to go do it.
Right.
So as soon as the,
the guy shut up the school,
the Korean community harbored.
Okay.
This kid did the appearance of the kid.
So that's why you can't find an interview online with the parents.
Like what the fuck happened?
Right.
The Koreans harbored the parents,
so you couldn't get the media couldn't get to them.
Then they shipped him to Korea.
The ship to parents occurring.
Yeah.
The Koreans don't live here anymore.
Wow.
They live in Korea hiding.
You know what I mean?
And Poo song or something.
Some village,
it's kind of a fascinating thing that when someone does something fucked up,
you never blame who made them.
You know?
Like,
if my dog goes out and bites people,
like all of a sudden you asshole.
You know,
what did you do with your dog?
Why is your dog so mean?
Why?
How come your dog wasn't contained in your yard?
But if your kid goes out and fucking shoots with people and shoots up a school,
nobody looked,
pulls you aside and go,
hey,
what fuck was going on when this
one was being made?
Yeah.
Jeff Dahmer's parents still,
you know,
defend themselves.
Like you can't defend that shit.
You can,
but you can't rather.
But who's to say that someone can't just be broken?
Who's to say that you can't just have normal people and this kid's just got a
fucking wild screw loose period and there's nothing you can do about it.
But can I say something,
Joe,
and I disagree with you on this point.
Okay.
Because you know I met your daughters,
right?
Shit.
These well-adjusted,
beautiful kids,
right?
I guarantee you they're not going to eat.
He'd somebody.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a poor example because that's just a few that worked out well.
And we're not talking about the average person.
We're talking about if there's like the thing about Dahmer is a perfect example
because apparently he was never abused,
you know,
and,
but his parents weren't together.
They weren't together.
But that doesn't mean anything.
And the father at,
when he would saw to Dahmer with a dead dog,
I brought home a dead animal right.
To my dad.
Right.
Look,
Daddy,
I found the cat.
Right,
right.
He beat the shit out of me until I could no longer even move.
Really.
And I never brought home dead cats anymore.
Did he make you eat it?
Right.
This is a,
this is a guide that was killing a bunch of things when he was really young.
Right?
Yeah.
But the,
the,
from what the,
he's one of the few cases that,
from what I've read online,
and maybe you know more about the case than I do,
but what,
from what I've read more online,
there's no evidence that he was ever molested.
Never had any stories about it.
Yeah.
And his parents were seemingly normal.
Maybe you're right.
But I think,
I think a lot of it has to do with up nurture.
A lot of it does,
but maybe not all of it.
I mean,
look,
if someone can be completely psychotic like that Virginia tech shooter or like
many other serial killers,
I mean,
who knows?
It might be a variety of things that can go wrong.
It might not just be nurture.
It might also be nature.
That might be possible.
But they're also,
I mean,
you can,
you have to admit though,
that there is a mental deficiency,
right?
Something going on and there are medications out there,
Decade.
Are there medications that you can give you a soul?
That's true.
You know what I'm saying?
There's some people that are sociopaths and they literally,
they have no feeling for other people.
All they think about themselves,
we know a bunch of them.
We know a few comics that are sociopaths and see as a clear,
so no,
no,
no question.
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
there's a disconnect between,
you know,
these people in reality,
for whatever reason,
and almost all of them,
it's some sort of sexual abuse when they're young.
Almost all of them.
Well I,
you know,
yeah.
Mencias I guess it came out in a different way.
That was what you're saying.
You know what I mean?
Instead of like slaughtering a village,
you can come out a bunch of different ways.
You could come out and drug addiction.
It can come out and you know,
prostitution and girls who do porn,
you know all my view.
But you know,
my view,
I've been seeing it,
you know that,
you know,
I see a side to him that no one like you guys don't see,
give some love.
I know,
you know,
I've always for a long time,
you know what I mean?
So I don't see associate paper that,
you know,
when will,
what was dom or like,
well he was a nice guy.
He always said hi and yeah,
maybe I am the,
then it was kind to me.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm the neighbor.
You're the neighbor,
right?
Yeah.
But the neighborhood doesn't get it.
No one knows that evil is evil to everybody.
I mean fucking maybe Ed gain had a nice cat and other he treated well fuck
fucking creepy to you.
And just in sense that like,
you know,
inspiring these huge movies like that sounds the lambs and yeah,
it's,
it's fucking scary thing cause he was doing it back when there was no other
examples of it.
That was just what he's supposed to be doing.
It's not like this guy learned about it in the movies.
He was making clothes out of people.
Right,
right,
right.
But I think that,
I think baking a lamp shade right is worse than making clothes.
They found lampshades from World War II there made it a,
not the Nazis made out of Jews.
All of those,
if I won recently was preserved.
It's horrendous.
No one's going to buy that.
Like,
how could you put that out in your living room speaker?
Some people did.
They make like clothing too.
And I like everything.
You're just lampshades like did they have roles?
I think they just fucking slaughtered people and did whatever they want it to
them.
Don't ever,
ever say to cross in front of me again.
Do you have in your house,
like a room devoted to Kim Jong you like,
like,
like newspaper articles over we'll wall circles and the private investigator.
Why would we maybe do you have,
do you know him?
Do you mean I know him because he seems like he would be your enemy right now if
I was you alive because it seems like he's in everything right now.
Do you feel some kind of tie,
know anything about the dude?
Brian has brain damage.
When he was a young man,
he was asleep and he lived out.
You know what I meant?
And for you made that has to be carbon dioxide was blown on his head.
A little bit of it.
I'm not kidding.
This is brain damage.
They say something to you.
Okay.
When I was born I saw all the shows that you saw.
Right,
right.
Cause we had,
I was lived in America and TV.
I listened to the Beatles.
You know what I mean?
I smelled high with my friends on a hammock.
When did your parents come here?
In the late sixties right.
And what's crazy about my parents that they didn't even meet in Korea.
They met here.
Wow.
But they met in a disco and they're both Super Korean.
There's a to Korean.
But yeah,
very traditionalist.
But I mean,
not a now.
So now you grew up in San Diego right now?
That's where I met Bobby.
When Bobby,
Bobby,
Bobby was a doorman.
Do your doorman,
the doorman,
it was like 97,
96 maybe?
Yeah,
maybe earlier,
maybe earlier.
Yeah.
It was a,
I just moved to La.
I'd only been here for a little while and I was doing a weekend at the La Jolla
comedy store and it was me and Jimmy Schubert,
Hobby.
I don't think he was still in Seattle at the time.
And,
uh,
we went to a strip club in San Diego and there was this Mexican gang bangers
that were like the real deal,
like tattooed tears in their face and the whole thing.
This one dude was,
he had these crazy murderer eyes and um,
you know,
and Jimmy Schubert was like,
I dunno what happened.
Jimmy was trying to get a dance from one of their girlfriends or something or
said something in one of the girlfriends.
And so the guy got up and he'd gotten Jimmy Schubert's face and Jimmy Schubert
was trying to apologize and Bobby Lee just got all crazy like fuck these fucking
pussies Bobby Lee like you,
like these guys ain't shit.
These guys are pussies.
And he was saying it like loud and the guys were looking at us and I just got up
and I said,
well,
I'm leaving right now.
Whoever's come with me,
he's coming with me.
I'm leaving right now.
Like I knew we were like moments away from someone getting shot.
Really?
I don't know,
metal has had to have street smarts.
Oh my God.
Talk about negative street smarts.
These dudes had tattoos on their face.
There's certain dudes where you look at them and go get these guys are posers
these guys who were murderers,
there's no question about it.
A shotgun,
we are 15 minutes away from Tiawana.
Okay.
And this is a,
you know,
this is the old days when it wasn't even hard to go back and forth.
Back in the 90s brow.
He needed a driver's license.
It's all you needed.
You didn't have to have a passport to go to Mexico or come back and forth.
Dudes were coming back and forth all the time.
Oh.
And cab drivers didn't even,
they could just drive back and forth.
It's so easy.
So we,
there was a lot of crime and dangerous crime.
It was like you would run into pockets of,
of like extreme danger.
And that's what we were in involved in a pocket of extreme danger.
And as Bob Dylan could fuck you guys,
you guys eat shit.
Fucking guys are pussies.
These guys are pussies.
Okay.
That's like saying it loud and I don't know if you were drunk at the time.
United going.
No,
no,
no.
Are you sober?
Like I was 20 I was 23 I just left my hometown.
Poway was where I'm growing.
I grew up Poway it's called the knowledge.
Yeah,
there's a,
it's outside of San Diego East at 30 25 minutes east of like downtown San Diego.
Right,
right.
And I didn't know much.
Okay.
I just do it.
Started doing,
stand up.
I wanted to impress you because you know what I mean?
You're a headliner and I'd never met headliners,
you know what I mean?
That he's a headliner,
so I'm willing to act tough,
you know what I mean?
And I came across looking at it.
Good fucking asshole.
Well,
it's not how you came across.
It was the threat that you had put us into.
You'd put us in a bit.
I apologized over the last 15 years.
It's just a funny story.
I still love you.
I likes to,
funny story,
but I just remember like this little motherfuckers gonna get me killed and I
remember that.
I remember it vividly.
He was so incredulous.
Even now we're waiting to get in the car.
Ah,
you guys are overreacting.
Like get in the,
I don't know what was wrong.
Yeah.
I'm like,
there's,
I've seen murderers before.
I've met them certain,
there's a certain tweak in a person's eye when they've already killed somebody.
Sounds like nonsense.
I was just in South Africa,
I did some shows out there,
three o'clock in the afternoon,
I walked out of my hotel room and all of a sudden I'm on the floor.
What?
Yeah.
I got,
why am I on the dirt?
Right?
And these two black guys from South Africa were rotting me.
Whoa.
And I,
and,
and I don't know,
have any smarts.
Yeah.
I mean like they were,
what would they hit you with something or they throw you out?
I walked out and I just could,
I saw these two guys kind of following me.
Oh.
Like I don't have an instinct right here.
I'm in.
And the next thing I know,
they throw me out of the ground.
These two huge black dude,
right?
And then like my face is in the dirt and they take my blackberry and I had some
cash in the other pocket.
You're right.
They ran off.
And then Ian Bagg,
you know,
impact.
Yeah.
Ian Bag.
And I looked for two hours for them.
But what are we going to do?
What we might do nothing.
Why would you look for it?
That was going to buy my blackberry offer them.
Oh,
that's good.
Like they're going to accept money that's worth money for your money.
That's the dumbest thing I've ever heard is telling you this happened.
And the thing is is I just don't have any street smarts.
Wow.
Yeah.
I just don't have that instinct.
I grew up in the suburbs.
Wow.
That's not just not having street smarts.
That's like,
that's like,
you haven't thought this out.
And Ian Bagg was down with this plan.
Yeah.
What's his problem?
He's,
he's from Canada,
I think.
Me and Bobby.
He's Canadian.
Other in the same apartment.
Wow.
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
That's the same kind of thing that Africa is very tricky,
isn't it?
It's crazy.
How long were you there for?
A month and a half.
Whoa.
What were you doing there from Mike?
I did a bunch of shows in Johannesburg,
Durban and Cape Town.
It's crazy.
It was crazy,
bro.
I did with great comics who have been see a,
not Mitzi.
I'm Pablo Francisco.
You keep getting them confused.
I know Pablo Francisco,
you know all those guys.
Gabriel glaze.
It was Pablo,
me,
uh,
Ian Horny Adams.
Wow.
Okay.
I saw a photo with you and [inaudible] online somewhere.
That was it.
Yeah.
So what was the experience like?
Well,
first of all,
what are the audiences like?
They're Africans.
No,
there's just white and blacks.
It's amazing words.
Do the best audiences I've ever played in front of.
Really.
You crush you absolutely crush brown.
Really?
Because comedy is only like 10 years old there.
Whoa.
Right.
And they get all,
you turn on the TV,
you see two and a half men.
All these shows.
Did they get from America?
Right?
They can't do it themselves.
No.
They have a couple of,
there's a guy named Trevor Noah who's a huge star out there.
Really?
Yeah.
And he's a black guy.
He's huge.
And there's another guy named Luis.
Right?
So it's new.
So like now know if you're a standup in South Africa,
you get ad campaigns.
It's like just Verizon and Trevor Noah.
You know what I mean?
Just huge posters.
It's a market.
Do.
Donna is now playing out there.
Who?
Jeff Dunham.
Like everyone's going out there now.
Really?
Yeah.
Rogan,
Joe.
There's plenty of places.
I don't get to go to America.
I got to get back to Houston.
I haven't been to Chicago.
I can Houston.
You're to fucking Africa.
But what I'm saying is,
is that if,
if,
if you know,
they don't know me,
you know what I mean?
And they're still coming out right?
They probably got mad TV.
Did Not.
They don't know.
No,
they don't know who the fuck I am.
I opened bro.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
I had already and all these guys go back to know horny is no,
but the thing is,
is that the producers of the show were like,
because Asians are third class citizens there.
Whoa.
We're like,
we're like the blacks of South Africa.
Right?
Oh.
So it's like,
you know,
we were like riding the back of the bus like,
but up until 10 or 10 years ago.
Really?
Yeah.
Did a back of a bus for Asian,
like back of the bus.
They just,
they were not,
we didn't,
we weren't able to vote rich 15 years ago.
Yeah.
So they view me as like,
you know what I mean?
Like [inaudible] which is crazy.
Hear me.
It is absolutely unfounded.
The ball,
you know what I mean?
So it's like,
so I went up first and I could feel every show did people going,
oh man.
You know what I mean?
Like just,
and I just know,
you know,
Bang,
Bang.
You know what I mean?
You could,
so you could feel that they were like judging you,
judging me,
but there was a feeling of like,
what the fuck is this shit?
Right.
Really?
How is that not judging you?
Maybe.
But the thing is,
I know as soon as I opened my mouth and I just said the first couple of jugs,
I had him on my side,
you know what I mean?
Wow.
You just crush.
You know what mean?
Because a,
they've never really seen Asians that have an American accent that done it
doesn't have an accent.
Right.
So that in itself is shocking to them.
And be me just talking like an American,
which I am and then me see being funny.
You know what I mean?
Shock them too.
Wow.
So it's crazy.
Yeah.
So you were there for a month and a half.
I mean,
how many shows did you do?
I caught a lot,
bro.
I did like,
I don't know,
35 Holy Shit.
30 to 35 book that there's a festival out there every year.
You should do it to,
it's 39 I'm not going to go.
I can't do it.
I don't want to,
I don't,
I don't like go on for any place.
I don't even like going places for four days.
I like three days and done in and out.
But for me it was just like,
you know,
cause I just ended ever been there and also,
that was,
it was just a slow time,
man.
Wow.
35 fucking days in Africa.
And did they pay you and gold coins and trunk and heads?
Yeah.
What's an aids?
Good?
No.
The food is worried about malaria is worry about you go towards Cody got
malaria.
Yeah.
Dude.
It's like,
it's like being,
he did it really.
Oh he didn't like being anywhere else.
Kind of like if you're in Cape Town it's like,
oh there's a coffee shop and uh,
you know what I mean?
Clothing store,
you know,
I'm mean Starbucks are there.
No,
there's another thing called this is the only difference is they rob you
everywhere during the day.
They have to have no,
people get robbed all the time.
Wow.
I that one of the producers of the show.
So yeah,
it was on the freeway during the day and some black guy just walked up to the
door,
his door,
her door and said,
I want the car.
She just got up,
gave him the car.
Well,
they pass on Africa police.
Is there a lot of flights?
Like,
like the whole,
no.
Dude.
Why would you tell me to go to a place where you get robbed all the time?
What's so great about it?
Because I'm just saying no,
because I just think that you're a great comedian.
Stand up.
You know what I mean?
And I just think that there's no one like you that's ever played there and that
you could clean up.
I don't want to hang out with the outward man.
We could just have a law and words over here.
They're hanging out with you.
I love them.
I called this a cell phone.
That's his,
his voicemail beat boy.
Oh,
I love that.
I love them.
Cool.
Yeah.
We uh,
we went Gaga on them when they first came out on the podcast,
but that's how I know about them because of,
because of us South Africa.
Oh.
Because of being a big there and also you don't feel,
so you found out about them way before everybody else.
Yeah.
And also those guys,
they,
even the way they look,
that's what some of the light of the lot of the white people look like.
How popular is DMT were in South Africa,
was it?
Yeah,
I know.
But you go to a,
like a hip hop stood have hip hop stores,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
There's a poster or whatever,
you know what I mean?
And you know,
and you know,
they have radio stations that play just regular music.
It's a normal place,
you know,
it's just all intense.
It's just,
it's just new.
You know what I mean?
Civilization is new,
right?
Yeah.
Man,
Joe Wise is new.
That's what's scary about it,
man.
And its borders so much wild shit.
But that's,
you know,
that's how Russell Peters,
he had had his first theater show in South Africa and that's how he got the
momentum.
You wanna Sorta,
but Russell's just,
first of all,
you know,
here's a huge following in the Asian community,
you know?
Yeah.
Tunes and Asians and they're just so happy that there's another comic like,
you know,
or a comic like him out there and they just come out and massive drove
supporting them.
The community is so strong.
Yeah.
But they don't support,
Russell sells out like that everywhere.
It's not just,
you know,
he's crazy.
Yeah,
it does too.
Now this is the row or he had that really,
yeah,
yeah.
Hits First Theater show was in South Africa.
How far is that flight?
Isn't that like 16 hours.
It's a 24 hour Gail,
cause you do 12 to Amsterdam and they use one of the 12 to South Africa.
God,
I know.
It's the worst.
Really.
It's 24 hours in the air.
You feel like it feels like two weeks in the,
in the air.
Oh my God.
You start sweating.
You know he starts sweating after awhile.
Right.
It must wreck your body too,
but yeah,
it was 24 hours.
Jet Lag.
Here's your lap.
It tears you up and you have to do business.
Business class at least tell me this,
what the fuck is going on on planes that make you feel so fucking bad when you
land?
Because I feel like I drink.
I feel like when I'm on a plane I feel like it's like the same feeling I get
when I do a show and have like three shots.
That's what it feels like.
The air quality here.
You're pretty much hotbox other people's insight here.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
and you don't know what you know.
People are just filthy animals.
Really sleep on a plane.
You'll always sleep with your mouth open because you're sit back like this and
like no matter if you look at it,
everyone has their mouth open.
So you're just sucking it in through your mouth.
What is the way around that?
There's no way around,
oh,
I went to a strip club in South Africa.
It was the worst place I've ever been to my life.
I did a lap dance from a girl.
I kid you not that look like dog,
the bounty hunter.
Oh yeah.
I can get in and that she had facial hair,
you know what I mean?
Huh?
Yeah.
Her breast was like,
you know what mean shriveled up.
Um,
it was awful.
She was touching him.
Yes,
he's touching me,
but I'm laughing the whole time.
You know what I mean?
So you did it on purpose.
You want to do for fun,
you know?
Awful.
Did you worry about getting robbed there?
No,
no,
no.
He just don't work.
That was happening.
I got robbed the last,
like the second to the last day I was there bro.
Wow.
So it was like my,
let me know.
So did you just let,
like when the guy stole your blackberry,
did you try to get another one?
And it seems like you know why?
Because I know I'm leaving this,
God forbid in place.
You know what I mean?
I could go back to it.
Siblings hate it man.
You're trying to get me to go there.
What's wrong with you?
You know what I'm saying?
In terms of this rap Joe,
in terms of like,
you know what I mean,
what you would do their business and wise,
you know,
it's all,
to me what's the most important thing is having fun and 24 hours in the plan is
not fun.
You know like I got a gig coming up in Australia,
I'm doing some place called Rudy Hill.
It's a outside of Sydney.
It's like the suburbs.
It's like oh I could get,
because it was like a last minute thing.
I that's cause I'm doing the UFC out there.
I like doing those gigs are doing the UFC and so the night before I'll do a gig
somewhere in Australia and I've done them in England and I've done them in
Ireland.
I've done them all over the place.
Yeah.
But I'm not traveling somewhere for 24 fucking hours to do an audience to do a
show.
Yeah,
I can do that.
I can do that in Burbank,
man.
Yeah,
I'm saying that in my car and do that.
it's not,
you know,
that's just too crazy.
It's too much of a commitment.
You,
but you know,
that's the only Emma,
when you were at a point point in your life worth right now,
the only winner revenue you're getting is like shells.
Right.
Just kind of have to go fuck it.
You know why?
Why fuck it when you just build up your audience in America,
man.
That's how I feel.
I mean,
I don't,
I,
there's nothing wrong with doing it and there's nothing wrong with traveling
with,
for me,
first of all,
part of his kids.
I have kids.
I can't just go somewhere for a month.
They would fucking drive me crazy.
But I wanted to see great white sharks and shit like that.
You know,
Tim?
Yeah.
That's kind of interesting.
I mean,
that was interesting about Australia too.
I've seen crocodiles and shit and rose and find out that fucking Kangaroos kill
more people than anything.
Kangaroos fuck people up in Australia.
They do.
Yeah.
There's big,
giant futile.
There's apparently two different types of kangaroo.
Forget what color the big ones are.
The big ones will fuck you up.
They're like 300 pounds.
It shouldn't make gut people the kick you with their
towed out there,
that's ramping.
Everything was trying to cash in Australia that they shipped there from a
different place.
Right,
because they had locus or something that they wanted to get rid of.
So they shipped these indigenous frogs from South Africa,
but that the locusts were so high up on these leaves that the frogs didn't eat
that locust or whatever.
So they just multiplied poisonous.
So today's will ramp.
Yeah.
People are so God damn smart trying to fix ecosystems it.
Fuck that.
Spray the bugs.
You spray we cunts.
Bobby.
What was M and m like?
What kind of what?
We met him and M,
right?
Yeah.
What was he like?
Did you meet him in him?
I did what?
I was in one of his music videos.
Oh really?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
he,
I got a call saying it will come down now because they need you.
Right.
So I came down,
I did the three sketches.
I played Sulu then I played an Eskimo in Wa.
Yeah,
yeah.
And um,
yeah,
he's nice.
I,
you know,
I hadn't met him before and that got to be Dr Dre,
which is great.
He has a huge black hand that just takes my little hand and it surrounds my hand
and it's so dry into perfect.
You know what I mean?
To a doctor,
Trey's hand and he's so gentle,
like a chai giant,
gentle guy.
He put his hand on your past.
She's huge.
He's,
if something happened,
he started lifting weights and got gigantic,
but he's kind,
he kind guy because I grew up with Nwa.
I love that stuff.
Yeah.
So it's like,
it was a big ice cube once I was the fucking coolest thing ever.
When ice cube said,
what's up Joe?
I'm like,
kid
knows my name.
It's great.
It's a trip.
It's so crazy.
The people that I want to tell.
I was in Miami that was in the front row.
I was in the front row was Gloria Estefan.
Whoa,
get the fuck out.
I didn't know who she was.
Holy Shit.
So,
um,
somebody backstage before I went up to
glory has to fonts and the audience,
it's Gloria Estefan is,
she's huge.
I go really?
She is huge.
So I went up on stage and this is what I said,
this is,
I'm an asshole.
Oh No,
no.
I get up onstage and I go,
ladies and gentlemen,
Gloria Esteban,
and then you know how they shined the light on her?
Like,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And she's blushing.
She's kind of waving to the audience and I'm still smiling cause I don't know,
I fucked
right and a bond.
And then afterwards she just left.
Let's do,
I was never able to meet her and I,
and if you're listening,
Gloria Estefan,
I googled you after that.
You know what I mean?
And I know all your stuff and I really sorry for the disrespect.
Maybe she thought you were doing like an Asian joke though.
You know why she's not Asian?
No,
no,
that you were mispronouncing it.
You know like you were doing like a character because I don't do that.
You know what I mean?
So like I trust me,
it came off fucked up hours cause even the audience went,
oh you know you could hear them.
That's hilarious.
That's what I mean.
And it went down.
I don't know what people like sports people aren't.
I mean I did this one commercial where these two old men and that was like
telling one old man to go get me a cup of coffee,
a cup of coffee.
You just got one.
It was like,
all right.
You know what I mean?
And at the end of the two I was,
I was laughed and they're like,
you know who those guys were?
I go,
who?
Stan Mikita and Gordie Howe who are huge soccer hockey icons.
Right.
You had Gordie Howe going,
getting you coffee.
He did it in a,
it was,
it wasn't like I was a joking kind of like,
can you get me one of those too?
You know,
it wasn't like telling him what to do.
I was not a hockey fan when I was a kid,
so I didn't know.
I knew Bobby [inaudible] was like a,
a name.
I knew it was a big deal.
And so I was working at the Boston athletic club and Bobby or used to come down
and work out.
And um,
that's,
uh,
one of the,
one of the first times I'd ever been around a professional athlete that had been
fucked up from his sport.
I did not know how bad some dude's got jacked by their sports,
but Bobby Orr had scars up and down both legs where he had some insane amount of
knee surgery,
was like 16 fucking knee surgeries.
So I'm crazy.
It might even be more than that,
but his knees were so bad that he would play racketball and if the ball went to
the left or to the right,
he would just lean and follow the ground.
Literally couldn't move.
It was the saddest shit ever,
man.
It was the saddest shit ever.
And,
uh,
he would get,
you know what a versa climber as it's like a,
a poll.
It's at an angle.
It's got handles for your hands and for your feet and you kind of,
you,
you go up and down,
up and down with this thing and it simulates that you're climbing something
first or climate can't it?
I used to have to put him on this thing.
I still help him and when I used to do is to have to get behind him and I would
have to hold his waist and he would put one foot in one of the stirrups and then
you'd have to kind of lift them a little so he could get his foot into the next
one because his knees didn't bend.
His knees literally didn't bend.
They,
they,
they went from like fully extended.
So like one quarter is take John Mccain's arms.
It was way worse.
Well John Mccain,
it seems like you can't move them past a certain point where your shoulders,
he's got bad shoulders and needs to rehab that shit.
You know,
I think rotator cuff,
I feel whenever I see him,
I feel bad because Asians did that to him.
They,
yeah.
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
It was torture for five years.
Really?
Yeah.
They put them in straps,
you know what I mean?
In rope.
That's a fucked up his shoulders.
Yeah.
Brilliant.
Well,
what do you think that would even happen?
Mattresses in car bag and maybe slid into third and
the bag with his hands.
That's,
that's really what happened.
They fucked up his shoulders and they made me play.
John Mccain was at Monte.
I met T I can look it up.
Shut up.
Put Bobby Lee.
John,
it sounds silly,
right?
They got the call.
I got the call that I want you to play John Mccain.
I go,
no.
They go.
Why?
Because people like me tortured them.
I'm not playing him to Vietnamese.
It's pretty distant for Koreans,
but you know what I'm saying now.
Right.
If someone said it's even getting Meese though,
you'd be upset.
Wouldn't be Vietnamese at all.
I love them.
Okay.
It's not that you don't love them,
but you'd be like,
you're an idiot.
You don't the difference between Vietnamese,
Korean because a difference.
Yeah,
there was a big deal.
Can you just say something?
The reason why I said what I said,
which part when you guys put not you guys.
Right.
When he bumped up to video I said,
I think that,
oh,
that junk and most people have no idea what we're talking about here.
Well,
I don't know if you read it online.
Yeah.
Well most people are not going to read the story about you online.
Bobby Lee once was playing around and said something about Vietnamese.
Wow.
That's you as John Mccain.
You look like Donald Trump.
Fuck Frank Caliendo
it doesn't it look up Bobby Lee is John Mccain and it just not looked like John
Wayne.
The reason why I said that was because of Gat Fan.
You don't like that?
No.
My route,
I wanted to know where my resentment,
what?
Why I said would say something like that in the first place.
People.
Yeah,
and it was because at that time he was way bigger than me.
You know what I mean?
And I knew in my heart that I could just destroy him on,
you know what I mean?
As a stand up and everyone was saying like they bothered,
bothered be done.
Right.
It bothered me then because he was saying he's the funniest Asian guy.
Avar right.
And I'm like,
I know coy,
I know Margaret Cho,
you don't,
I mean I know a lot of Asian comics that are very funny.
Well you know what he had was a killer five minutes,
you know,
on,
I saw dad fan,
I was the one of the judges for a last comic standing on the fucking kid
destroyed man.
I mean he came out and destroyed.
It wasn't the best material in the world.
Yeah.
It was like,
you know who,
who cares?
You know?
It's like pop comedy.
That's what he was doing.
But he destroyed and then for whatever reason he really,
he was really funny.
But for whatever reason it just never caught on after that.
That was it.
But the thing is is that I know I'm on the club level,
right.
And I know exactly what he can do.
Like in terms of like,
if you were to put dat,
Mi Khoi like any of the other Asian guys,
other than that,
you know what I mean?
That it would,
you could,
would be able to see,
don't you think that that's corrosive thinking?
Don't you think that,
that,
that kind of thinking is a detrimental as a,
as a person to you?
Like when you worried about what other people can do and comparing your center
now I don't,
because I know when we were saying,
okay,
it's like,
you know,
Ken,
John,
you know,
his success,
I'm very happy for him because I've done,
I've went on tour with Ken.
I mean,
we did the Asian tour,
right?
Right.
He's been on 1516 sketches at mad TV.
I know his level and I,
and he's a hard worker.
Nice guy.
And is a talent.
Right.
Okay.
And you know,
I feel the same way about Jo Koy or Steve Byrne or any of these guys,
right?
Yeah.
No competitiveness with anybody.
But I just,
I just know,
you know what I mean?
At people's talent level and I just felt that he didn't deserve it.
Yeah.
But what do you care?
This is my point.
Like why,
I know I'm old,
but Jill,
I'm better about it now.
Of course you are,
but you're still sort of defending it,
right?
No,
not really.
I'm not really detecting I,
that's what I'm saying.
What I asked is do you think that that behavior is corrosive by saying you're
better than that?
Now you're saying yes,
it is negative,
right.
It's very negative and you know,
it was a bad time.
Really bad time.
For me,
it's tricky with comedians when we were talking about someone else or,
oh,
that gets jealous about people.
There's,
there's,
it's very tricky with comics for some reason,
when comics see one person success,
they've somehow or another thing,
it is being taking away something from them yet is that it's an end.
For me,
it's like I,
I have accepted,
you know what I mean?
I accept what I have in front of me.
I love my life,
you know what I mean?
But at the time it wasn't turmoil.
Like I wasn't really,
you know what I mean?
I didn't know what I was doing.
You know what I mean?
And I was going,
you know,
I had just gotten sober again.
You know what I mean?
So it was a rough time,
you know what I mean?
Just,
you know,
you're just sensitive in our mailers and so,
yeah.
I mean I,
in retrospect it was really ugly.
Yeah.
My point of it's one of those things you have to learn from now.
You know,
you,
you see it so much in the open mic night days.
You remember when you were an open Mike night guy and you were,
you're just starting out and then there'd be guys that you work with.
It started getting work.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Dude.
Everyone would hate,
I would hate,
I totally hate on people that would start,
I'd be like,
this guy's going to be good with fucking him was,
but he's obviously good enough to get a job.
Like,
you know,
it's not what hit him.
Getting that job was not taking anything away.
This is,
yeah.
But the thing that we learned over time though is,
is that you realize there's so much work out there,
right,
that there's,
I feel like there's enough for everybody,
but at the time when you're not getting jobs,
you know what I mean?
You know that you're funny.
It's just a difficult transition corner,
man.
That's all I'm saying.
Is it because Dat Pham is a Vietnamese?
Does that have anything to do with it?
Uh,
no,
no.
Because I know dat from San Diego.
First of all,
he's a liar.
I remember like during the show,
he said he'd been doing it for two years.
I started with the guy,
you know what I mean?
In San Diego.
I mean,
I have photos with him,
you know what I mean?
From back in the 90s so he had been doing it a long way long,
Living underneath a desk,
all these things that he said he would claim claiming he was doing.
You know what I mean?
It's not true to me.
It was not true.
And also Margaret Cho wrote him a letter because he had stolen a joke from her.
What joke was that?
I Dunno what,
Jock,
you know what I mean?
Asian jokes.
It's very tricky.
It's like what a buddy of mine,
my friend Jon Tobin from New York is to say this,
that when you work with a a bunch of black guys,
he goes,
it's uh,
it's always,
if there's three,
there's three comics and two guys are white and one guy's a black.
The black eyes always like,
yeah man,
I was supposed to be closing.
I heard her.
I was supposed to because he goes,
unless there's two black guys in the black guy,
then they're like,
yeah,
I'm supposed to open.
I got to get out of
why he was all the black shows.
That is so fun.
It's so true because there's so much hack shit that guys would just rely on
cause it would work every time.
Now you're white people looking around,
seeing if you could laugh at this Jewish material.
Every person that's a Jew has to talk about them being a Jew and it's like they
all did the same material.
When I went to her with uh,
on the fork,
three Korean for Koreans,
we didn't kings of comedy,
it was me,
Steve Byrne can and Kevin Shea and no one wanted to close while we would like
kind of fight backstage like I,
you know,
I mean I had have to close sometimes,
you know what I mean?
And it was very difficult because there's so much that we went over the
material.
It's just the fact that,
you know,
all Asian comics have at least 10 minutes,
right.
Of their act about being Asian.
Right,
right.
The point of view might be different or the angle.
Right.
But you had all those probably have the most material,
right?
Yeah.
I have the most material,
but yeah.
But now I asked you to kill her shit is Asian that do you still do that bit
about the the Vietnamese guy hiding in the camp?
No.
Fuck it.
That's why they win.
The war that can hide,
they can hide in trees for three weeks was just a banana.
That was,
it was a killer,
but I was in that video you were talking about,
right?
Just before that we put up the,
uh,
the one that you got in trouble for that video.
Yeah.
Then you talk about it and have video.
No,
I didn't.
no,
no.
And I don't blame you for the video,
by the way.
It was just one of those,
well,
for a couple of years I couldn't even look at you.
Why?
I'll be honest with you.
I didn't say anything.
Can I just say that I tended to get this because we haven't talked about it.
I just want to bring it up.
Can I bring it on shore?
Anything?
Okay.
There was a time about,
I don't know when,
but two of the years that I felt that there was animosity between me and your
camp was because of the filter from me.
Yes.
I did.
It really,
for me,
I felt,
I felt that I honestly,
I felt that,
could I be,
I love it.
Yeah.
Is that I felt that there was a weirdness because of the whole,
the video that I had come out.
No.
And,
and with Ari,
you know Mimi already not getting along.
Look when,
when I called you,
when there was the video that you made where men,
Sia made you make seven.
Yeah,
I called you about it.
I know.
I told you.
I go,
dude,
I'm not mad at you.
Yeah,
no it doesn't.
But you will.
Which was,
which was the one biggest mistake I thought because if you read the feedback
after that,
oh my God,
I get threats.
Yeah.
Well,
you
know,
I understood your point of view.
Totally.
I knew you from back in the day and I knew your relationship with him and I knew
that you knew he was sick and you were trying to help him.
I knew,
I knew the whole story.
It didn't bother me at all.
And of people for people don't know.
He just made this video saying that he never saw it,
but can I play?
Can I tell you how that came about?
Okay.
But let me tell these people.
He made a video saying that he never saw Carlos stealing and material.
And it was one of those videos where it looked like one of those terrorist
videos where there's a fucking gun pointed to your head and that's been a knife
under your neck.
Okay.
Connect.
Oh,
so this is what happens.
I'm in Canada,
right?
The video comes on,
right.
And then Mitzia calls me and I,
I literally six months ago,
I erased the message.
I kept it for that long and that's why it was so,
he was so angry.
I can't even go.
It's so great.
Yeah,
I erased it.
Dammit.
So then what happens is like I come back from Canada and I now it's the new
season of mad.
Right?
And Lo and behold,
mencias might've been Seattle got picked up.
Right.
And it's literally attached to that TV.
I think the studios are right.
So unlike,
I had,
and I hadn't seen Carlos since the video went out,
right.
So for a couple of days I'm like,
I can,
I know how to get around.
I got to that,
this out.
Right.
And I'll sneak around the back here.
This is how I want to get that right.
Well,
next thing you know,
he grabbed one of his cousins pro,
comes to Matt Davey,
who's a friend of mine,
brings me over the right.
And then I had like six Mexicans just sit me down.
Really Max,
I don't know any of
their Japanese,
Guatemala.
Um,
and you know,
Carlos was there,
ned and he just goes,
once he sitting in a throne,
it was outside and he just goes,
you,
you got to do this for me.
So I did it.
You know what I mean?
And then that happened.
And then,
you know what I mean?
We're just part about the video though.
What sucked is,
is that you've made this video that didn't even seem like you are given new.
The video you were talking about,
like it almost seemed like whatever,
I can't remember the actual words in it.
It sounded like you were talking about a video that you hadn't seen,
which was even weirder because I got,
I got caught between,
you know what I mean?
Two camps that I,
you know,
I mean I,
I've always had a relationship with,
right.
I mean it,
Joe and I have known each other for,
so I have a camp don't mean people,
human beings not camp.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
And then,
you know,
men,
Sia had a group me his group.
Right.
And I felt like I was in the middle and that,
you know what I mean?
I felt like at a time where I had to choose,
I felt like I stayed on of it.
You know?
I mean for the most probably like I,
for the longest time I wouldn't talk about it in radio or anything like that
because people would bring it up.
I'd go on tour and they were like,
so,
you know what I mean?
And I'd be like,
I don't want to talk about it.
You know what I mean?
As far as just like the amount of interest generated by that,
that's probably one of the most controversial videos.
And like the history of comedy,
he probably going to sound kind of crazy.
It was insane.
But you know,
it also kind of crazy was you remember what the environment was like before
anybody called them on that where everybody was on egg shells.
You're constantly terrified of that guy walking in the room.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
And the news becoming successful is becoming successful.
And then just like I said,
you know I,
I just don't see that part.
Let me say that.
But how can you say that?
Cause you do,
you did because it starts to shit from you man.
I mean I know you had issues with,
okay.
I know.
Can I just say this though?
All right.
Here's what it is.
Okay.
Like we said before,
okay.
That it is like,
you know,
one of those situations where the guy,
when I was at an open miker right.
Used to,
he bought me a car,
it was a used car but didn't have a car.
Right.
And then he took me on tour and Pauly shore like would rotate.
Like one guy would take me.
Why don't you know what I mean?
Who was more fun to hang out with on the road?
Obviously Paulie because he didn't make me cry.
You know what I mean?
I used to get pussy.
You can't get pussy at him NCO show.
Why not?
Because they're,
they're all married and have 19 kids,
any domain and they're like,
oh,
any men CFN I,
you know,
I love you.
But my point is,
but my point is,
is this,
that,
how did he make you cry?
What?
He would make me go to golf with him.
He like,
he plays golf and I hate golf and I'd have to get early and carry,
you know,
bring the golf bag.
You would have to bring them,
I did it once or twice and I stopped going at,
you know what I mean?
And then tell you that one time.
Oh No,
no,
no.
One time he out.
Let's move over that and then you carry bags.
One time I had to show,
we played Denver once and he made me sleep.
I didn't give me a hotel room.
This one he wasn't doing as well you like it was in the beginning and I had to
sleep in Albert's closet,
the fuck on,
you know his brother clause on the road with them and you didn't even get a hold
just as he wasn't selling out at the time.
This is literally in 96 [inaudible] 95 you know what I mean?
But so you know,
you,
you know you,
he is like,
he was always like,
you know a brother in a sense.
You know what I mean?
You,
you know,
regardless,
you nurtured,
you nurture me.
Like I think that though.
Did you cry?
What made you cry?
Just having to like get up and like,
you know,
there was a time where you have to sell merch and a,
and as a young comic,
you know what I mean?
You don't know what to do.
You want to make it,
you don't get you what you appreciate the stage time.
And it was just so,
he makes you work for him and on top of just opening up for honest,
a lot of guys do that shit dude.
Really?
I,
cause I have openers now and I treat them with the utmost.
Yeah,
Pauline does all the time.
You know what I mean?
Didn't Pauly you to work for free didn't Paul?
Uh,
I can't.
That's another,
I can't,
I cannot do you had discussed that?
No,
because that's another,
you know what I mean?
It's what it,
what it is.
This okay is Mitzi is one thing.
But Paulie,
right.
He specifically made me a regular,
they're like,
he made his mom passed me.
Right.
And so there is a specific relationship.
No one on planet earth talks to me.
Like Paul,
he talks to me in what way?
He talks to me like I'm literally his younger brother still.
They,
and I understand it cause you know,
I've known her for so long,
but in the rural,
in the world,
I'm almost 40.
You know what I mean?
I don't let anyone talk to me.
The Way Paul,
he talks to him,
talks to you in a disrespectful way.
It's just like d like he'll say did in me.
Like he'll say stuff like that.
You should be bigger than you are now.
You know what I'm saying?
The little bit.
You Bitch.
Yeah,
but the thing is no,
I don't say that.
What happened with you and see you,
Eh,
I have to go to the comedy store once in a while.
I want to burden anybody.
Know what I'm saying?
Someone talking to you like that's not nice.
Yeah,
but Paul,
it's all so you know,
you know when I moved out like big brother though,
you know I moved,
lived in his house.
You know what I mean?
You lived in his house.
Well he charged me rent.
But the thing is is that you don't any pop me on the road,
so it's that he really bad.
I'll be back
one second.
Okay.
Is that cool?
Sure,
go ahead.
So Joe,
there's going to get a story straight.
Just going to go in there.
No,
I don't have my stories and if I sat about Pauline,
no,
no.
I could tell.
I'm just kidding.
We're just walking around.
Turn around.
So Joe,
I saw a movie last night.
You,
I know you already bought it.
I guess it's not the way it's called.
Enter the void and it is like somebody saw you talk about DMT and tried to write
a script around it,
around some kind of living in Tokyo.
I mean,
well maybe they just did it,
Huh?
Well No,
they,
it has a lot to do with DMT.
You know what I'm saying?
Maybe they did,
but how they describe it in the movie sounds like they're reenacting you.
It's,
it's,
you're going to fucking like the movie was made for you.
It's amazing.
And then it gets really annoying.
But like the first half of the movie,
it's like,
wow,
this is fucking cool.
But they show a DMT thing.
What would that,
what it feels like to be on DMT for the first half of the movie.
And there gets parts where it sounds exactly like how you describe it.
And then whoever directed the movie,
which his name is,
hold on one second.
Uh,
it's directed by Gaspar.
Noe.
He is brilliant.
I said come out on DVD.
That came out Tuesday.
I just,
uh,
it's on Netflix,
Netflix streaming HD too.
But it is so amazing.
If I ever make a movie,
I want to make my movie look exactly like this guy is brilliant,
but then it gets really annoying.
And there's all these like what are going to know him?
Well,
one of the directors things is like,
it does like the strobe light thing through it.
It gets so bad that I feel like I'm getting hypnotized.
I get this movie was made by Google or the government and it's like you'll,
you'll see what I mean.
Like you'll sit there and like,
I'm going to have a seizure.
I'm having a seizure.
Wait,
I'm being programmed to do something.
All right,
this,
you know,
it's know
an Olympic logo that they had a poll because it was giving people epileptic
seizures.
What was the Al Roker thing where Al Roker I listened to it on an opiate,
Anthony,
it was pretty fucking funny because a,
opie and Anthony were shitting on Al Roker for good because Al Roker was making
fun of epileptics.
He said,
so if you're still watching this,
if you're not flopping around on the ground,
you know,
and so he starts making fun of it.
And then the next day it comes back and says,
I was only making fun the ad.
I was
never making fun of epileptics.
Right.
Which is total bullshit.
You see this though.
It's amazing that there's not fucking five warnings on the DVD it before you
even watch it cause it's so bad that it feels like you're being fucking
brainwash for that dude that we had on the message board that how to whose wife
was epileptic and she would watch certain avatars on on people's screens that
flashing avatars.
What was his name?
Jim.
He's a nice guy.
I hung out with them.
He was a Marilyn Manson's webmaster.
Really fucking good dude.
I hung with him and his wife and his wife has some weird condition where she,
if she sees anything flashing strobing those little animated Gif files that flat
toto,
she would just tongue rolls back,
eyes rolled back in,
her head falls onto the ground.
This movie would make her pregnant.
That's how bad it is.
I mean it's fuck is it with people that certain things just make your brain
shutoff like flashes and to understand that like if you see this,
you'll feel sick to your stomach.
When you see parts of this movie,
you'll have to turn away and like look at the ground for like the movie could.
The movie is the director.
You'll fall in love with the director.
The movie is so good at the beginning and interesting and just you'll never see
anything like it.
And the trips,
the visuals of your stone when you see it,
you might have a panic attack.
I watched it in three d last night and I was like,
I am tripping right now.
I feel like I'm on acid right now.
Then it just gets boring and confusing and don't tell me what would I want to
watch it then if it is.
No,
no.
It's interesting.
I mean it's still,
I like it,
but it just kind of fades off after it gets,
it's really cool.
And then it Kinda just kinda does.
You and I don't always agree on movies.
There's probably a few movies that we see.
They're moving,
they're reversible,
irreversible,
irreversible.
Know what's that about?
It's a movie that played backwards,
right?
And it's,
it's,
it's notorious because there's a five minute rape scene in it in a tunnel.
Right.
Which I swore to God,
that most brutal thing I've ever seen in my life.
It,
and people online say it's the worst rape scene ever.
You have to see it.
[inaudible] it's a Japanese movie.
No,
it's termin or some shit like that.
Nice.
Yeah.
They're fucked up.
Human Centipede.
Not into that.
Not into watching people get raped.
I watched food inc the other day.
Great fucking disturbing man.
I watched it on the way home from,
uh,
from West Palm Beach,
Florida and uh,
it's disturbing shit,
dude.
When that,
that lady started talking about her son dying and about her son got eco-line
from Jack in the box burger and how he was suffering at the end.
I had to shut it off.
I'd even the seventies Jack in the box had a big controversy where not only one
person died,
but a bunch of people died.
Right?
Well,
yeah,
from their food to Food Inc is scary as fuck.
You know?
And I've had some people email me and tweet me saying that,
well,
it's not really that bad.
This is propaganda.
They're just trying to shock you.
But how can they be trying to shock you if they're showing you reality,
right?
I mean,
if,
if what they're showing exists on any level,
it's terrifying.
When they show these cows that are kicked in manure and this one cow it,
there was a plastic ring and there's,
his stomach was exposed.
Yay,
we're reaching into your stomach.
I'm like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
And how about chickens?
Man,
if you,
if you didn't know,
I mean,
look,
if you like your cheeseburgers and you'd to go to Wendy's two o'clock in the
morning,
and I do too,
man,
don't watch this movie.
It's going to fuck with your head.
But this,
um,
these,
these chickens,
they give these chickens,
steroids and antibiotics and all kinds of things and they fuck with their
genetics somehow or another to get them to grow so ridiculously big and plump
that they can't walk and he,
they die all the time.
They just fall down and die.
Not Foster farms.
Foot of like Chinese.
Yeah.
They have those commercials about how they plump them up and put salts and stuff
like that.
I mean,
it just make them really fat with like salt and water and stuff and foster farms
as hold.
Their whole advertising is based on that.
So there are advertisers based on,
they don't use hormones.
Right.
Okay.
Well that's good to know,
man.
It's good to know.
I mean,
there's gotta be a humane way to make food.
If it costs a couple bucks more,
it's worth it mean,
I don't know how much more it would cost to not have cows.
Duh.
I'm down with eating meat.
Okay.
Don't get me wrong.
But,
but the way that they're doing,
the way they're producing meat for,
for,
you know,
for fast food and for,
it's just,
it's fucking crazy.
It's just,
it's totally beyond being humane.
It's beyond that.
It's gotten to this factory consciousness less,
you know,
like just feeling lists place where they're just stuffing all these animals and
these small areas and getting as much bang for their buck as they can.
And they may,
they make this food,
like they make an Ipod,
like it's a factory system,
right?
And if there's no love or care or,
and it's just,
let's make the product.
That's what people make fun of Chinese all the time for the things that they
eat.
Like if you ever going to do a Chinese market,
you can get anything butterfly wings or,
you know what I mean?
Or the shoulder of a mere cat or whatever.
I mean,
like really in anything.
But the thing is,
is that Americans eat way worse,
right.
With these collars,
you know what I mean?
Just tainted meat.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
People think that,
well also,
first of all,
China has a billion people and it's self sustainable.
China doesn't import food from anywhere else,
so that's pretty crazy in and of itself.
They're able to feed a billion people.
When you feed a billion people like that,
you gotta eat bugs.
Okay.
That's what's going to raise a restaurant and bank on some shirts.
Animal Dick.
That's all they do and there's a six month waiting list to get on into this
restaurant.
Watts animal deck,
Bangkok.
How do you order that?
I'd whisper.
There was Anthony Bordain show the other day where they were serving animal dick
soup.
Apparently.
It was really good.
Yeah,
it's supposed to get your bureau.
Wow.
Check this out.
Yeah.
That movie you brought up your first of all,
whatever it's called,
and I moved the,
I was talking about same director.
What are the fucking odds of that Shit,
dude?
Really?
That is insane.
That's insane.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was a good movie.
This director,
I made the mistake of watching her,
but you'll love every visit for reversal.
That's crazy.
But you'll stop at the five minute rape scene.
You'll turn it off.
Well,
that was,
I was saying,
I was so sad when I was watching this woman cry.
Their son died from Jack in the box.
I was like,
you know,
this is just bombing me the fuck out.
I get it.
I get the foods fucked up.
The whole situation is fucked up.
I don't,
I don't really need to keep going here.
It's just,
it's like,
what are you going to do though?
That's the big question.
You know,
the problem with us is,
you know,
with everybody,
as you're always doing something,
you're busy,
you're hungry,
mean we're going to do,
there's a supermarket,
but you don't have to,
especially on the road.
Yeah.
Especially,
I mean that the waffle houses up and you're like,
okay,
I have to go there.
You know,
the road gets creepy.
Yeah.
As far as food choices go,
I always bring vitamins with me and I try to eat as much salad and stuff went on
the road as possible,
but I don't understand how they don't have 24 hour restaurants in small towns.
All right.
If everyone closes 11 it's like you can't eat anything.
You'd have to go to the wall.
I've been,
I've been to Walmart,
Walmart's at like three in the morning just getting like fruit,
you know what I mean?
And like just surviving.
Yeah,
food.
Yeah.
If you go to small towns,
there's no 24 hour food.
Yeah.
That's a tricky thing.
And,
and you know,
you're staying at the Holiday Inn,
there's no room service.
Yeah.
I've been to something we talked about a couple of weeks ago came true when we
were talking about how people's jobs are getting taken away by robots and stuff
like that.
I was at El Pollo Loco yesterday,
which is like a chicken Mexican chicken place and they had the order yourself
kiosks out.
But now where you sit there and menu screen,
like Taco,
a special instructions,
no,
a Burrito and then you pay for it,
like kind of like a grocery store and then they just call out your name and give
you your food.
So he cut out the person that cut off the cashier and it's actually nicer.
It was so nice because a lot of times you order,
but you don't even think like,
yeah,
I would like extra tomatoes on this,
but I don't know how many times you've been in a fast food place and your talk.
It's like who?
There was a girl in the mad TV that have really funny sketch about that.
There was a girl on mad TV.
She's very pretty,
and she had a very funny sketch about a girl who was a the counter how,
but she was always loud.
Bong Kooky.
Yeah.
You want one?
Angela,
Angela Johnson.
She's very funny.
Yeah.
That girl had a really funny Vietnamese and Nail Salon and a bit of like 10
million hits or something.
She used to sell out on the road from that bit,
which just killing it.
Yeah.
And how many minutes does she have as an act?
22 minutes.
2030 minutes circle.
I had heard that she was a middle and she was middling and crushing and filling
places,
and then the headliner would go on after him and half the people,
at least devos doing that now.
Really?
Yeah,
no,
he's a,
he was in New York.
He hosted,
but now he's closing,
but he closes with 30,
which is fine.
Well,
what he should do is host what God should do if they're not really bring a bunch
of good comics on the road with you and host,
you know,
I watched Charlie Murphy,
uh,
develop an act from nowhere.
You know,
I've met Charlie two years into his,
his journey,
you know,
and I watched him as he was trying to put together as act and Charlie went right
to headlining man.
And it was fucking hard.
Fucking,
you see that?
The honorable hotline get booed.
I'll get booed off stage.
Yeah.
And it's that room.
That room is so retarded.
What room is that?
What?
Here's what I'm saying,
crowds.
So none of that's what I'm saying.
Exactly what I didn't say that at all.
So what did you say that was kind of rooms are walking around hard,
difficult.
We're taught it was the wrong word.
Black crowds shock that Sundays,
no,
not crowds are failing.
They're not rooting for you to get back on,
on your feet.
What I'm saying is,
is that I go on,
I go on the road,
right.
And I get black people to come to my show and they're,
they're legitimate fans.
Right.
And I love them dearly.
That's not what I'm talking about.
There's a cultural thing.
You mean when you go to a certain areas like south Philly or whatever,
right?
And you do a shell and it's all black,
Even in the lineup.
Right.
And you had to perform.
It's the most difficult situation ever,
right.
For a guy like me.
Well you know,
it's a different kind of crowd.
And I think the good thing about those crowds is that they don't let you be
indulgent and they want your jokes to come quick.
They want to come quick.
Yeah.
They don't,
they don't want to wait around.
Also tonal,
right.
Your,
your co you can't be monotone.
No,
you got it.
You know what I mean?
Cause some excitement,
attitude,
tone,
you know what I mean or whatever.
You know what I mean?
Cause now I'm like,
I used to be more energetic.
Now I just kind of talking like this because it would be,
no,
not only that,
it's
no is because it's,
it's pace.
Right.
You know,
when I first started headlining,
I wanted to do what I did as an opener,
which is go out and Gung Ho,
get them,
you know what I mean?
As a headliner and then 15 minutes in your or you're out.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You just can't do that pace for 45 minutes.
You got to,
first of all,
it's not fun for the audience either.
You've got to create a show.
That's what I'm saying.
When you go to see a movie,
it's not,
you know,
an opening gun scene.
It lasts for 90 minutes and then the thing shuts off.
You're like,
what the fuck did I just watch?
Yeah.
So now I build,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
But,
and then you have peaks and valleys,
but in black rooms it's an,
you can't do that.
Can't do that.
Well,
there's no peaking.
You just keep hammering.
I just feel like you have to be like earthquake and just hammered away.
Well,
he's hilarious.
He's going to do it and would it,
how long does earthquake do?
45 but he's at,
he is,
if he's like perfect,
45 sprinting uphill.
Ah,
shooting all the way.
Yay.
Throw your backpack back and throw them lie on your graph.
Once you lose them,
like you know white room,
when you lose them,
you get them to think to him,
I'll get them back.
Right.
There's no getting black crowds.
Yeah.
Wow.
I want to try it.
I want to try it black.
You will die.
I will die up there.
You will get barbecue.
I did.
Most important thing with black rooms is economy of words as well.
Short attention span.
You've got to,
you got to hammer home with bits.
I did a,
uh,
my black version of my set once a flappers in Burbank and it actually killed,
it was like,
do you mean the black first?
I like,
I just do it more like he said,
instead of like doing your jokes normal,
they kind of be like,
I went to the store the other day.
I had to get a hat and my girlfriend,
she's just starting out or whatever his name is.
He is.
Is he a zoo?
A zoo as he an Zari?
Yeah.
It's kind of like his,
his,
uh,
whatever his daughter is,
you know,
it's kind of like that,
but it's just starting up.
It worked though.
That's what I'm saying.
Here's Phantom,
the laugh store.
First of all,
I don't even know what flappers is.
Flappers in Burbank and he's a good club.
Never been there.
I may never play there.
I heard it's good.
It's really,
it's really nine heard.
It's nice.
I knew you'd like it.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
I know,
I just don't do well in those kinds of things.
What do you mean you don't do well?
I don't do good in,
um,
Haha.
Uh Ha ha.
Caffeine.
Yeah.
Why not?
Because I don't know what it is,
is just because I think what it is is because it's free.
Oh.
The audiences not paying to go there and say what is that what I'm saying?
What I'm saying though is,
is that you're doing,
it's a free set.
No,
that's not what I'm saying either.
What I'm saying is that there's two types of audiences I feel.
Okay.
The one that's why I don't comp when I do well on the road,
go on the road.
Because of the fact that if you comp right date,
there's a general feeling of like,
you know what I mean?
It's not a good show.
Exactly.
We know me,
but when you have people pay,
right?
People are respectful.
You don't have to have it as many hecklers.
You know what I mean?
And I'm fine.
I don't care who comes,
but the thing is is that ha ha right?
They don't,
not only do they not pay you,
but you have to pay for your drinks that can I get a red ball?
They go,
it's three adult and whatever.
I'm like,
I'm playing it for free.
You know what mean already there's a sign,
there's a feeling of disrespect and I don't know what flappers is like,
but I just don't like that.
Disrespect is a real club.
It's okay.
It's nice.
I know what you're talking about.
You don't.
You do some fringe clubs that are used to dealing with open micros and doing
dishes.
That's what it is.
A disrespect.
Go and do a set there.
They don't,
they don't treat you different.
Like,
well,
here's a paid seasons.
I don't need a dude.
I don't need much.
All I need is this.
Can I get a drink for free?
Like a bottle of water?
Okay.
And in town,
of course I'll do a millions free showers,
you know what I mean?
And um,
to be respectful.
Isn't it funny how places like that or just a little bit outside of the city and
there are different worlds,
you know,
it's a different world,
but it's different when you do north Hollywood.
Do how,
see races you've never seen before.
Like is that an Aztec Indian,
whatever you want to be like I think has died off or something.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Where's your favorite club to working on it?
Seattle.
Comedy underground.
Know what plays parlor.
Live parlor.
Live.
If it does that.
No.
Part of the life is a new club there and it's attached to one of the Microsoft
buildings.
Yeah.
And it's like if there's a,
it's a nightlife.
If they have pool hall and Dance Club Comedy Club in one,
how big is the quantity club?
Huge.
It's like not huge,
but 306 300 right.
And it's one of those places where I sell out in Seattle.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's a little outside of Seattle,
but it's like 15 minutes from the city.
Right.
And it's called Beaumont.
Okay.
And literally it's clean like the,
you know,
the stage is nice.
You know what I mean?
The green room is clean,
brand new couches,
you know what I mean?
It's a nice,
nice environment.
You make a lot of money,
you know what I mean?
And,
and the end,
the key,
the kids know where the people that are in the audience are nerdy.
They make money.
Right.
And they just,
they're just happy to be there.
Here.
I mean,
it's weird how parts of the country or not hit by the economy and other ones.
That's one of them.
Yeah.
When I was in West Palm,
they were telling me that,
no,
we didn't really get hit by the car.
I know it's crazy cause it's all the retirees and the old people with money and
I mean I'm sure some people from west palm like fuck you,
we got hit.
But the club was like,
they didn't really,
they were really didn't suffer like Kansas City.
I went and they suffered.
It feels like there was a suffering.
That's the kind of place like Iowa.
Yeah.
It's the whole thing.
It's so strange because I don't understand the economy,
so I'm always like,
okay well I guess it's better now.
It was a better now is it coming around?
It's not,
not like my parents for the last 35 years owned their own clothing store.
They had owned business,
you know,
it was called at first it was called fashion gala.
It's a little clothing store for fat ethnic women.
Fashion girl.
Yeah.
Cache it.
Cache Passion Gal fashion gala.
Yeah.
And so it's like cater to,
it's like lane Bryant before ethnics.
Okay.
And they did fine over the last 30 years.
As soon as the economy hit.
I mean they went bankrupt,
you know,
mean I had to pay for their mortgage and they are destitute.
Bam.
It is tough.
They live in Phoenix,
you know,
it's tough for them.
It had a fire.
Their whole staff,
now they work and they're in their seventies whoa.
Where do they work?
At the same place at the store.
The date it's called changes now.
And they,
they,
they do shifts.
Like my mom will do the morning shift.
My Dad will come in and there's a bottle of,
there's literally a bottle of pis like up a chug of pis because they don't have
any employees.
Right.
So my dad has a piss in a jug.
Oh my God.
Right.
Because you can't leave,
you can't leave the store and it doesn't have a bathroom there.
No,
it's in the mall.
Right.
So it is sad.
But if he has the shit,
he just holds it.
What?
Well,
let's,
it's a turtle head situation.
Die.
He could die.
He should get a diaper.
So everyone go to,
what's it called again?
What's the name changes.
She got everyone going to change.
It's in Arizona.
Would partners outside of the Chandler or something?
Fuck Mason,
something like that.
Yeah.
That's a scary thing.
Being an old person,
you know when your body is slowly starting to fade away and you're still
laboring every day.
And by the way,
that takes years off your life.
You know,
getting up before you want to working,
doing things you don't want to do all day.
But I told my dad,
I go,
dad,
you don't have to work.
I will eat.
How much do they need at what,
2,500 bucks.
3000 a month.
Right.
To get by.
Maybe even less.
Right.
I said,
you know what?
you know with the unemployment and then social,
social security,
retire and I'll,
I'll take that over.
The rest does Virginia.
My Dad said,
well if that don't work I guy.
Wow.
Right.
So I go,
all right,
keep working cause I don't want him to die.
You know?
Good call.
Yeah.
But it's sad because he,
he's,
he's still got that ethnic,
that Asian work ethic and man,
that's good.
They have to work.
It's a trippy thing is fucking crazy,
dude.
Yeah.
It's a very weird thing,
man.
The only people's mortality and parents,
it's weird when you realize,
especially your parents get to a certain point in time,
you realize you probably have more information in your head about the way the
world works in your parents do because your parents grew up in a totally
different,
totally different time and they weren't curious when they were young.
Fucking,
it's a strange,
strange thing,
man.
It's,
yeah.
It's actually kind of sad.
It is.
And it's going to be you someday too.
Maybe you think you'll have kids?
No,
never.
no,
no.
You gonna get snipped.
Go Doug.
Stan hope style.
No,
no.
Just hope.
No,
because I masturbate so much that what comes out.
It's like advising drops.
Yeah,
and it's done.
That's it.
How many times a day you masturbating?
I do now a couple of times
Missenden to lies once.
Maybe.
How often do you use the flashlight?
I don't haven't used it in six months.
Really?
You just go use your hands as ted?
Yeah.
What's wrong with you?
Why fleshlight feels better.
Yep.
It didn't have to heat the oil,
an athletic cool.
Then I had to put the batteries in the back.
You know,
speaking as sex.
There's a fucking,
there's a story in the news today and apparently it's a legit story.
There's a man who's suing a Glaxo Smith Kline,
the pharmaceutical company and he's alleging that there's a drug that they gave
him to treat Parkinson's disease that turned him into a gay sex and gambling
addict at one years old.
The guy,
it said,
the 51 year olds lawyer says their client's behavior changed radically after his
first administered a drug in 2003 for the illness,
which causes tremors,
blah,
blah.
The Ma,
the man is a married father of two says he has attempted suicide three times,
claims you became addicted to internet gambling,
losing the family savings and stealing to feed his habit.
He also became a compulsive gay sex addict and became exposing himself on the
Internet and cross dressing this risky sexual behavior,
the risky sexual encounters that led to him being raped.
His lawyer said his behavior stopped when he stopped taking the drugs in 2005.
By then he had been demoted in his defense ministry job is suffering from
psychological trauma resulting from his addiction.
So we just went on a,
uh,
gay sex gambling rampage.
That's not what happened though.
No,
but listen,
man,
you're not right.
You're just not true because I put this up on Twitter and a bunch of people who,
uh,
you know,
neuropsychologists and a bunch of different people are qualified,
started sending me like I got like six or seven tweets from people who either
studying it in school or actually doctors in the field and they were saying that
it's a,
a dopamine agonist.
I think that's the word.
And that,
um,
it,
it does facilitate addiction and it can interrupt your,
a natural patterns.
And I agree with that.
All right.
But what I'm saying is that it does well if you have an addiction of exposing
yourself and doing gay sex that's been hidden inside you for many years.
So you think this was just out of the,
out of the blue,
what sound?
I want to suck dick out of the blue.
He's taken a crazy drunk.
No,
not out of the blue.
Maybe it seemed more exciting to him.
Maybe it never like regular sex.
He's 51 years old,
maybe regular sex just got so tired of getting laid.
I mean,
think about another 11 years for you.
You're 40 years old,
about another 11 years from now,
you're like,
God,
I'm so tired of pussy is so boring.
And then somebody gives you the drug.
You're like,
why don't you go suck some cock?
And you're like,
why don't I suck some cock?
I might have to dress up like a Carl.
I've heard this phenomenon it when,
when?
When people are so jaded with sex,
like rock stars or whatever or whatever that it,
you know what I mean?
They get so tired of it.
It just turns into Dick.
You know what I mean?
Well,
I don't know.
I don't agree with that either.
I think Dick was always in the,
you know,
in the pitcher.
Yeah,
but I think everybody's got their own little story about how the,
I mean,
there was a lot of bisexuality going on the seventies like according to many
people,
Mick Jagger and David Bowie and Lou Reed,
all that.
But I think a lot of that was like the,
you know,
probably one crafty gay dude talk to all these other things.
You know,
it's just cool man.
Yeah.
And plus they're all doing acid and Shoreham anyone,
their consciousness and you know,
it is like one of those last taboos.
It's like,
okay,
well let's stop and look into why is gay sex such a with this?
Okay.
If you're fucked up,
like you're fading,
you're on,
you're drinking,
you're almost in a blackout drunk in domain and you're with gave a boy and
you're a big rock star and delay of David boy pulls out his penis.
Right.
It's like suck it,
you know?
I mean,
I don't know.
I would want to,
you have to be blacked out drunk.
When I was just saying was maybe they're experimenting with different ways of
looking at the world.
You know,
maybe they're being an artist and being like a rockstar,
being a creative person.
There's a lot of people that are creative people that are willing to take weird
chances and do weird things just to see what,
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with it.
So what he's saying,
you know,
I mean I,
I have gave the people that represent,
don't go there.
Stop when I'm saying I'm not racist.
I have black friends.
Okay.
Right.
You're right.
But what I'm saying is,
is this I the I,
I don't have anything I have no against,
wasn't because of the pills.
What I'm saying?
It's just that,
what's this guy's name?
Ted.
Ted Haggard.
Tagger right.
Just out of the blue.
You know what I mean?
He does.
Man Ever said out of the blue that he,
he said he was gay the whole time.
He never said that.
He's been doing three interviews recently where he says he was bisexual the
whole time.
Yeah.
He said what his issue is.
He said.
That's what I'm saying though,
but that's not what you're saying.
You know what I'm saying?
That okay,
but this guy that never had any sexual encounters.
Yeah,
that's what I would think that Bobby,
what Bobby's saying is probably true too.
Like he probably had it in the back of his head because of socialization.
Right.
He just,
he just refuses to address it and I agree that that the pill did something to
open his mind up.
Maybe you're a man,
but I feel like that,
that,
that instinct is,
there it is.
Okay.
That is a possibility.
Why would you want to decide one way or another without being that guy?
Why would you even make a judgment call and like how the fuck could,
you know what causes gotta to do gay sex?
And once you go into his past and interview them and find out like have you ever
been attracted to guys?
Did you ever have a wrestling match?
We got a boner.
Unless you tell my why even,
I mean,
it is possible if,
if attraction and all these different things are really neurochemical reactions
that we have inside of our mind or inside of our brain,
if we figure out a way to stimulate certain parts of the brain with look,
I mean,
think about what we can do as far as like antidepressants and all sorts of
things that affect mood and neurochemistry.
What if they can give you something that makes you attracted to the opposite
sex?
What if they can give you something that you're gay and all of a sudden you like
girls or give you something where you're,
um,
you're,
uh,
you're heterosexual.
They were trying to do that in Iraq.
They were trying to come up with a bomb.
The CIA was,
they actually put research and development into this.
A gay bomb.
Uh,
got Obama.
They would detonate and it would be some sort of a chemical agent.
It would go into the air and it would make all these soldiers become rabidly
attracted to each other and they would lose morale there.
Just start fucking,
but I even think I'm the strongest of ecstasy.
I never wanted to suck a dick.
I mean acts to see,
we're now talking about,
I know,
but like
any drug with switch,
that very specific,
uh,
affection,
reaction,
but it doesn't make you sexually attracted to someone.
It is possible that there could be something as strong as what ecstasy does for
you in terms of affection and sensitivity and feeling for things and,
and a loosening of insecurities.
It's very possible.
It's something else could do it in another way that all of a sudden makes you
gay.
I mean,
if you talk to a gay guy,
like we have gay friends and not you and I together,
we have gay friends,
she out the gym.
I'm going to see Bobby.
Hey,
go watch music.
When you know,
when,
when you talk to them,
they never feel like there's something wrong with them.
You know,
they,
they feel pretty fucking normal.
So what is it that separates,
you know,
like,
uh,
I can't say his name,
but the dude who's our friends,
there's the piano guy from the store.
Yeah.
Great fucking guy.
So what is the difference between him and us?
Well,
the only difference is that he's attracted to men.
what is,
where's the connection in his mind?
Is it a chemical door that gets open?
Is it a a chromosome thing?
Is it a genetic thing?
What,
what is it?
You know?
Yeah.
Do you know they,
there's a theory.
There's one,
oh,
hold on.
There's a theory about homosexuality.
And one of the,
one of the more interesting theories was a firm,
they did a study in Rome.
And what they found is that when women are promiscuous,
especially like habitually promiscuous women that constantly cheat on their man,
they have a disproportionate amount of gay sons and they believe that what it is
is a variation of the x chromosome.
You know,
women have double x chromosome,
men have x,
y,
and they believe that there is a variation of the x chromosome amongst certain
women that makes them incredibly attracted to men to the point where literally
they can't even fucking control themselves.
Like they're,
they're are number one.
Obsession is getting new Dick.
They just want to get new deck all the time.
And this gets transferred into their sons and their son.
All of a sudden it has this incredible attraction to men.
Wow.
Totally makes sense.
Because haven't you met girls like that?
No,
he never met a girl.
That's just a fucking freak.
We've all met girls that just seemingly this poor girl was broken and she just
can't help fucking everybody,
you know?
But the only way to truly find out if this is true is for me to take that pill
and I'm not going to do it.
What doesn't exist,
but I mean this,
this drug exists,
this one.
But here's the thing.
It's one guy,
okay.
How many people took it and it just cured their Parkinson's.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm saying though,
Joe.
No,
no,
but that doesn't mean,
listen,
it doesn't mean anything because look how many people are addicted to peanut
butter.
I'm not.
I just had peanut butter and I'm fine.
If you get peanut butter to guys addicted to peanut butter,
he fucking dies.
His throat closes up.
He can't get any air in.
There's a biological variation in human beings and you have to take that into
account.
What if for this guys,
for whatever weird tweak,
he takes his fucking drug and it goes on a gay sex rampage.
You might totally right.
It
might be a freak and he might be just a loser.
He lost all his money and that's why he's suing this company.
Okay,
how about this?
How about this?
Can I say this?
You'll have a does my money is I take the pill that let's,
I'm that guy,
right?
I take the pill.
I didn't want to gay sex.
Get on the pill.
I go on a gay sex rampage.
Right,
right.
How about me just not taking it ever again?
Well,
I'm like that.
I wasn't just that and nothing in the pill.
Again,
this guy also lost all his money on gambling.
I think that's,
he hit his bottom.
Don't take the pill anymore.
Well,
you,
you're a 12 step guys,
so you understand the bottle that the shit with people are in denial about that
shit.
You know what I mean?
It's a weird thing when you're around people that are in denial about what
caused their issues.
Right?
Yeah.
And there's also,
I know that doing drugs and that,
that kind of behavior isn't the root of the problem.
There were the problem is something else.
Those are just symptoms.
Right.
But if a guy is or has been shown to be a fine upstanding human being,
I mean,
I don't know this guy's history.
That's the problem with having this stupid argument or this conversation rather,
when you lose that much money and gambling immediately,
that's a red flag to me.
Like,
okay,
this guy is probably,
but it wasn't until after he became,
um,
got on the medication that he started gambling.
Apparently he didn't gamble before that.
The handlers are often,
you know,
they tell the truth.
I don't,
I don't have a problem with gambling,
but I easily could have,
I was terrified of it when,
uh,
when I used to play pool and I used to be around a lot of gambling addicts.
I was around a lot of them guys who are,
and I see them and I would say this is scary shit,
whatever you,
obviously gambling is fun and it,
it becomes too much of an addiction to these people.
Whatever it is,
don't,
don't do whatever the fuck they're doing.
Can I tell you it's what happened with gambling.
I was in shock for a lot of really improv and I put $5 in the machine.
Okay.
And I,
I pressed Boko was a,
is the hard rock casino hardrock right.
And all of a sudden the thing just went crazy like I did anything.
You know what I mean?
Just crazy.
I don't even know what happened.
I got a combination or something.
Right?
Then all of a sudden like people are surrounding me,
right?
Like people are back backing me for these people.
Just all the people watching,
I hit a jackpot.
So you're worried someone's going to Jack your job and they got somebody else
turning around like,
oh yeah,
this is great.
Right?
And then the lady comes because it says that press,
you know,
cause you get a ticket,
right?
You can't get a ticket because you know it's so much money that they're going to
have to give it to you.
Right.
Nice Lid.
He comes up to me,
she goes,
congratulations.
I go,
thank you.
They go,
um,
so can I just see your id?
I gave her the idea and she goes,
I can't give you the money.
I go,
why?
She goes,
your license is two months expired,
which is,
it is.
So I go,
no,
I want my fucking money.
And they get,
we can't give it to you.
I went to the top Indian chief,
like I'll counsel number and I argued with them.
Two hours later,
I'm an officer.
I,
you know,
I played the Improv year.
I,
you know,
I was packed.
Every room,
they come here to gamble.
Right,
right.
It's two months expired to kicking me a fucking my neck that I need the money.
How much?
It was like $2,000.
Hmm.
Okay.
But the idea that I wanted Jackpot and they won't give me the money.
That's against the law.
It's an IRS thing.
You need a valid because you're just said,
all right,
hold my money.
I'll go get my renewed be back tomorrow.
No,
I live in,
I live in La Dude.
Right?
Yeah.
It costs you 2020 casinos.
Like hold your smile.
I got,
you know,
like they,
I got,
I gave him my number,
I go work it out with their counsel.
They have to go back.
You know what I mean?
And they never called me.
I couldn't get my money and I was so fucking mad.
I'm still upset about it and I'm Kinda,
well,
they had an opportunity to fuck you and they took it.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
But it's,
that's so fucked up.
It's fucked up that,
that's not seen.
Illegal casinos aren't in the paying out business during the you gambling and
losing.
I know,
but here's the point though.
I go there every year.
They know me.
Like I go to the H.
Dot.
Dodd the desk.
Right.
Everyone loves me.
Bobby's back.
You know what I mean?
Like I,
I know that people come to Campbell at the casino right after my shows.
Right.
I feel like I've provided a service for this.
They can't fucking,
you know what mean one little claws?
Like look through it.
Well now you understand the true nature of your relationship with them.
They don't give a fuck about,
you know,
that's the nature of the relationship by the way,
with fucking virtually every casino and player,
you know,
the bottom line is the,
the player is a,
is a mark,
you know,
and that's what it is.
And the mark you,
it's just like,
you know,
you,
you let them win a little bit,
let them get a little bit,
make them feel like he's got something going on.
He copied my room.
Hey,
you want a nice meal?
And even though we lost some money,
we had a nice meal.
We went to see a show,
you know the contest we went to see the fucking the lion king.
And that's what happens man.
But the bottom line is those fucking like go to these gigantic places like the
Venetian or the Bellagio fucking huge fountains and shit.
Who's paying for that?
Yeah,
we are.
you'd be,
you're paying for it by losing.
Right.
But what I'm saying is that if I would have one like a bigger jackpot,
like $2 million,
I don't know what I would've done.
Yeah.
Like I would have physically assaulted in American Indian.
Holy Fuck Man.
I would've lit her for the rest of my life.
Make them cry.
That would have,
I would have freaked out about that.
I would have,
yeah,
that's an issue,
man.
I would still be fighting that,
that whole thing.
Yeah.
You get your 2009 I lived through it,
but it,
you know what you should start doing is doing a bit about it on stage.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
that's a bit,
yes.
There's a funny bit and there's somebody out there is something in there.
Yeah.
Come on man.
There's a funny bit in that,
you know,
because,
but I'm,
they can take your fucking money.
They had no problem with you gambling.
So you're risking your money but you can't get a return.
What you should have done,
you should have got a wait.
Did he print out a $2,000 ticket or cause here's what it is.
Okay.
If you win,
you know,
at,
at a slot machine,
you get a ticket,
right?
Anything other over 1200 it that you win is considered a jackpot.
Okay.
Then they have to come out.
So then they had to fill out IRS forms in this,
that if I just would've let me had less than a hundred dollars less than I would
have been able to take my money,
you know what means Christ and that,
you know what I mean?
I would have had a cutout would've spend it at the casino anyway.
They would had it in the end.
You know,
did I would've gotten to a higher machine,
you know what I mean?
You know,
I would say I just want a good time or put it back in the community.
Yeah.
It was something like that.
I always want to say it like that.
The community,
um,
it's fucked up.
What is it about black people that they said community like that.
They see
a lot of things a little bit with that,
but that's a big one.
Community community put it back in the community.
Yeah,
they say that.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
um,
what happened?
So there's no way you can get this money back to this is gone.
You're writing it off as a loss.
You got to do a bit about this problem.
But the thing is,
is that um,
I called y'all,
how could he help you?
Well,
he owns at the Improv,
right?
He has a relationship with the hard,
what did they say?
There's nothing I can do.
I mean,
and I'm like,
but it's,
it just,
it,
it doesn't make any sense because they know me.
It doesn't matter.
They don't give a fuck about you.
You now you at least you know what the deal is.
The deal is now.
Yeah.
It's,
that's also probably a rule that they can't circumvent.
I mean,
who you're talking to is probably a guy who's going by corporate by lines and
this is the rules person doesn't have a driver's license.
I mean,
even though they know you have to kind of assume like who the fuck,
you know,
if you can't write down a valid driver's license in the receipt so they can get
tax,
it just seems that they should be,
should be able to hold it for you.
Like I seems like,
yeah,
you want,
you have credit,
$2,000 credit,
you come back here with your license will give you the fucking money,
but until then we're holding it for you.
It seems like that's what casinos do anyways because they have,
you know,
you go there like you're Jay z and stuff like that.
You have like a,
you know,
like almost a bank account with these people who Jay z.
Do you know what I mean?
I bet you you can get your $2,000.
I googled,
I googled my name.
You googled your name in front of them like an asshole.
Oh,
did you really?
Yeah.
Go.
Listen,
I play this place.
I'm a headliner.
Right.
Googled your name
right.
And it went to my Wikipedia page.
Right.
I went to my Wikipedia,
I go,
here's my picture.
Here's what my birthday,
you know what I mean?
I'm almost 40 right.
You know what I mean?
Because I had no idea.
I don't know what else to do.
Right.
We don't give a shit.
They didn't care.
No.
Sounds like a scam to me.
And this is an who's telling you this?
Who's the person saying American India would beats in his hair,
you know what I mean?
And he was upset at you or no,
it was just basically just really cool about and just like,
I know who you are.
I'm so sorry.
These are the rules.
Well,
I guess those are the rules.
Here's the rules.
Now you've got to write a bit about it.
I'm going to it.
Yeah.
You have to make it a $2,000 bet.
It makes me so fucking mad.
That makes me mad.
I don't need the money.
It's just a principle of that.
Absolutely.
I get it.
Yeah,
but it does make sense.
I mean,
it doesn't make sense that they can't,
they can't hook you up trying to me,
doesn't it?
Not to me.
No,
it doesn't make sense.
Because Joe,
if I work,
I basically work for that casino sort of.
You work for Joel?
I worked for tool,
but he has a relationship with them and it's not like I don't play there every
week.
You know what I mean?
He just sorta rents there.
Right.
He does rent a rule.
Like you rent the rooms there but you,
you understand what I'm saying?
It's like in a sense I give them business.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Do you like going on the road?
Do you dug it in some places?
Yes.
Some of them are like,
I want to kill myself for a long time.
You didn't go on that.
Refused to do it.
Yeah,
because remember when we were back in,
uh,
when I was doing the store,
we would talk about it all the time.
You weren't going on the,
I refuse to do it.
And then we were somewhere recently,
like I think it was San Jose
and they will say,
yeah,
Bobbie Lou just here,
pack the place.
I was like,
Damn Bobby,
that's the only,
that's the only reasonable.
Now I go,
because when I used to go a little bit before,
no one would come.
Right.
What,
what,
what changed that?
I don't know.
It was,
well,
here's what it was.
I would go to a market now what my thing is,
this is I go to a market first and at first they don't really know me or if they
do,
they don't know that I do stand up.
Right,
right.
So I do a weekend for pretty much for free.
They give you a guarantee it.
Right,
right.
And then the second time back,
it's always better because I know that I deliver.
Right.
You know what I ended up,
my show is good.
You know what I mean?
And so the people that saw you,
they come see you and they bring more people.
Then the radio,
I love radio.
You come back,
like if you say you do a Gig,
how long before you come back?
A year.
A year,
yeah.
Yeah.
And how much of your material be new in that year?
Maybe,
and I'll be honest with you,
not as much as maybe the next guy,
but after about 10,
15 minutes,
10 15 minutes,
we'll be in the new in a year.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm not,
because I'm not that prolific really.
But the thing is that,
here's what thing is,
is that a lot of my stuff now is improvised.
Like they have moments of just playing with the audience.
A lot of that.
Right.
And also my thing is there's a element of crazy in my shower where I usually go
in the audience and do crazy shit.
You know?
Like what?
Like,
you know,
like if somebody will get up to go to the bathroom,
I'll chase him out of the room and follow them to the bathroom.
Really?
Yeah.
And then I'll say,
yeah,
while the audience is the love,
the love it,
you know what I mean?
And I'll pull my pants down.
I'll,
I'll be in my underwear,
I'll follow them into the bathroom.
Have you ever gotten in trouble for pulling your pants down at?
Yeah,
I did this one thing where like I,
I wanted to give a guy a lap dance.
So he came on,
he came on stage and you know,
and I there the music is playing and I got,
well you on Parkinson's medication and I got naked and I had a sack come out and
you can tell that this guy was extremely homophobic really.
Right.
So there was the music's playing and I jump on top of him.
Oh,
it's my late wife sitting on the stool.
But he literally picked my body and through,
you know what I mean?
And I hit the ground,
you know,
me on my back.
Right.
That got knocked unconscious for like a split second.
What you hear like little like storms.
Did you hit your head?
No,
but I heard
so what hit that made you see stars like that?
I hit my back and my head maybe a little bit,
maybe your head a little bit,
but I also took the wind out of my body.
Right.
Okay.
Well we
right.
Yeah,
I got Jack and I jumped on,
jumped on it because you do that because nothing he left.
He just took it because the thing got a laugh.
When he threw me off of me.
It got a lot.
You got to laugh.
So he enjoyed it and I stood back out and I looked in his eyes.
Right.
And he kind of went that guy,
he kind of liked the laugh.
Right,
right.
So I did it again.
Right.
Cause you got addicted to the loud.
Because that first it was hatred.
Right?
Like get off me Geek,
you know,
kind of,
Whoa,
that is what he said.
You know what I mean?
That's the,
he said it,
but in the eyes I can tell that there was a group so that when I fell down,
we connected.
I'm like,
okay,
I can do it again.
Wow.
Like a sense.
You're right.
That's a word.
That's the worst thing that's around.
It's a weird thing,
right?
When you're ad libbing with someone,
you don't know exactly where this is going to go.
That's exciting though.
It's fun.
Right?
It's exploits also to you and I both came up in the store and the store.
We
talked about this so many times in the podcast is store for all it's terrible
qualities.
The best thing about it is the fact that no one was paying attention ever.
There's no crowd control.
There's no one that's,
the comics are forced to take care of audiences themselves and sometimes you
just deal with incredibly hostile on saints.
I've never worked at a club consistently where there's more insane shit
happening at [inaudible].
Here are the comments.
Go.
Yeah,
this tough room is tough.
I know you don't.
You don't even know what you're talking about.
They don't even know if it doesn't work.
The store,
like there's so many people that like to be like,
yeah,
the police is evil.
I know.
Don't do the store.
The store is evil.
It is.
Yes it is,
but I would give it say evil.
There's,
there's some,
there's a quality of evil to it.
I think that qualities because the fact that it's Ciro's nightclub,
the fact that it was Bugsy Siegel's place,
you can't get past the fact that people were murdered in that place yet,
but it's also has to do with the color of the building.
Yeah.
I really believe you can't paint your walls in your bedroom.
Red Blood red because it's psychologically it's not good for you.
It makes you angry.
It makes you ain't like silver too.
I tried to paint my room silver ones and they go,
it's not because you'll feel like you're trapped in a,
you know,
I mean space shit.
I feel like black,
you know,
like in a cage black.
I don't know what it does.
I was thinking of painting these walls.
Black,
not done.
They give you,
okay for a podcast.
Perfect seat.
This is the color,
what Walter's put.
These are neutral colors.
These are nice,
relaxing.
I feel very good right now.
Do you feel good?
Yeah.
I feel like this is the color.
I'm going to leave it here just for you,
Bruh.
Like coffee.
It took so long to get you on the podcast.
I'm going to leave these things.
The reason why that was the case,
right?
Oh No,
no.
I know it was because I just things going on,
right?
It's just like,
yeah,
I'm as flaky as the next guy,
but the store,
why don't you come back,
come back?
Where the store,
oh,
never.
Never.
I can't.
Why?
Because I liked the improv better and there's no negativity there.
The improv,
everyone's so super courteous though.
The,
the,
the staff there are so friendly and,
and thankful and kind for years he dealt with it.
The store then pretending that the store was the star and you were lucky to work
there.
Know you're lucky to help out.
No matter what you did,
you can never do enough.
It was an energy when you were there.
I bring it everywhere else.
I know,
but I'm saying that I'm,
because I used to either go up before or after you in the studio.
It was hard to go up after you,
but sometimes they would put me up after you,
but there was still an energy and the alar.
I swear to God,
that's different than it is now.
Not that,
that we don't get an audience,
but it's a different kind of vibe here.
Well,
I was bringing my,
my specific thoughts on,
on comedy,
my specific thoughts on life is let's have fun.
Let's not take things so fucking seriously.
Let's look at all this shit,
but let's be nice to each other and let's have a good fucking time.
That's why one of the reasons why when everything has been crazy would happen at
the store.
I would always make it a big point to by everyone in the audience a drink,
you know?
I mean,
when I kicked somebody out,
yeah,
I did that.
Oh,
there's like a dozen times I would kick people out and then I would spend
thousands of dollars buying 300 people drinks,
you know?
Yeah.
But that's like what the what,
why,
why did you leave in the first,
because it's not,
it's not Mitzi shore,
it's club anymore.
See,
the whole thing that happened was when the men,
Sia Shit went down.
I called Mitzi,
who's the owner of the club and Mitzi and I've had a relationship way back to
1994 when I first met her,
when it first came to Hollywood and to me she was the,
you know,
the queen of comedy man is the comedy store was Mecca to me.
To me it was more important,
and this is not bullshit to get past as a paid regular the store than it was the
fact that I was on a Sitcom in,
in California.
I was on the Sitcom and I was like,
acting sucks,
you know,
is a lot of money.
I was making all this money,
but I'm like,
I'm a fucking paid regular to store.
Like Holy Shit.
I couldn't believe I was there.
I mean this is where Richard Pryor,
it started out,
David Letterman was there in Kennison was there and all these Hicks had worked
there for awhile.
So to me it was like all this history.
So I mean,
not only had I worked there for free for all those years where I was on fear
factor,
they put my name up on the marquee.
It would say,
you know,
fear factors.
Joe Rogan packed the place.
We would promote it on my space and to me it was just,
I was just,
it was a workout room.
It would,
I would get to fuck around a stay sharp,
do a long set each Friday and Saturday night.
So when I would go on the road I always had material I could still do special
and still do fear factor at the same time.
So it was a perfect situation for me and I could help the store I worked for
free and as matter of fact,
even money that they owed me from years ago,
I paid it back in the,
in the form of a tax free donation.
Yeah.
And then I paid for the whole sound system in a place.
Yeah,
you did.
I took out the speakers,
I put in,
you know,
a CDR burner and the fucking dat player in new re microphones cords,
the whole deal.
Right.
And then when this whole thing happened with them and see,
which they knew for the longest time that he was doing,
everybody knew what he was doing,
but they were making money off of it.
So they turned a blind eye towards comedy.
And what I've always said was that if you're in the business,
if you're a,
if you're an agent or if you're a manager or if you're a club owner,
you're selling art.
That's what you're doing.
Yeah.
And when you got one person who's stealing the art of the people that you're
selling,
and then selling it again,
that's what he's doing.
He's like,
he's cannibalizing.
You have to put a foot down and stop that.
And if you don't,
if you say crazy shit like,
well,
you know it's business and he's making a lot of money,
well then you will clearly are not on the side of the art form that you actually
make your living selling.
So when all this shit went down,
I called Mitzia,
but to let her know that,
you know,
Brian made this crazy fucking video and it's about to go out and it's,
it's ugly.
And I told her,
I go,
the guy's a problem.
We've had problems with them for years and we're going to put this video.
She goes,
[inaudible] just keep away from 'em.
Just don't,
don't get crazy.
I go,
man,
I'm never going to hurt him.
I go,
I'm not going to do anything crazy.
You have to,
okay.
Do you want to go up tonight?
I go,
yeah.
She goes,
last time,
whenever you want to put me up.
She goes,
okay,
10 o'clock.
All right.
Thank you,
Mitzi.
I love you.
I love you too.
That was the last word I ever spoke to her.
Okay.
I get off the phone with her.
They call Tom.
He calls me an hour later and tells me I'm band,
so why?
So I go,
what are you talking about?
I go,
I just talked to Mitzi and hit this stutter and cock suckers.
I,
whoa.
Oh,
well what about me?
Me,
me May,
may,
may have Nancy's a confused.
Nancy doesn't know the fat,
so to me it was very clear that there was like some situation where Mitzi was no
longer making the decisions.
It was no longer her club.
So there was some other people,
whoever the fuck they are,
Tommy was at though the mouthpiece or whoever the fuck was making decision and
clearly they had made a decision to go and have men see a headline that weekend.
I make a big deal out of it.
And he was on the radio.
It was like for him to try to save face and then have me band.
And so I said,
I'm never coming back.
I'll,
I'll go,
I'll tell you this right now.
This is it.
I'm never coming back.
And so that was years ago and I've never come back.
But I,
it was the best thing for me because after I left there and then I started
working out at the Improv like,
God,
it's so friendly here.
The vibe is so much better.
Everyone's happy,
they're,
the managers are happy,
the comics are all,
it's like it's a cool bar area where everybody hangs out.
And then I started doing sow's and more recently and just,
you know what,
man,
I just realized that there's comedy clubs out there that appreciate comics and
that's,
those are the only people that you,
you should hang out with.
I'm,
I'm thankful for my time at the store.
I learned a lot there.
I learned a lot about,
you know,
hecklers and dealing bullshit.
And I learned a lot about,
I just learned a lot about the business from this whole thing that happened for
getting fucked over.
So for me it was,
it was the best thing.
Well,
Tommy didn't go to anybody,
by the way.
I think it was all him.
Yeah.
I mean,
Tommy night,
whatever.
I mean,
I,
I'm a regular there.
I get spot to anytime I want to.
And Tom is a friend.
I've never called them awful.
The job,
I called them four spots.
I mean,
but I know that he makes decisions.
I'm sure he does,
but not that one.
I don't believe that,
you know,
I don't,
I don't believe he,
I ordered this happened,
he went to Mitzi and heat.
He didn't go to med.
So he didn't talk to her at all.
I know for a fact.
So who,
cause when he talked he talked to somebody else.
Who other fuck it was,
whether it's Pauley or whoever the fuck is maybe Peter,
whoever the fuck it is.
It might have been Peter.
I don't know who it is.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I didn't ask.
I didn't care.
And then ever since then have they called,
you know,
oh,
he sent me one ridiculous letter.
I saved it.
It's hilarious.
The most one sided fucking letter ever talking about,
you know,
don't destroy the store,
build it up.
And like [inaudible] I worked there for free for fucking years.
And then they would always say like,
everybody works for freight and none,
not everybody doesn't do what I did and what doesn't put their name on the
marquee.
Okay.
Put up on my space and be told the globe oil.
I'm gonna tell you about La Jolla.
And I started in that room.
Right.
I go there six years ago,
five.
I haven't played there in six years.
Right.
Okay.
Six years ago.
I call them the lawyer.
I go,
can I go up,
cause I'm gonna go down to visit a friend,
right?
They're like,
yeah,
sure.
So I drive down there,
I show up at the club and the manager goes,
you can't go up in La Jolla.
And I go,
why?
He goes,
well,
this is an all girl shell and they're from La and they don't want to pick it up.
I go,
who is it?
They'll at least a sunset people I've never even heard of.
Right.
So I just drove down here.
They said I could go up.
I'm from this call.
I fucking built.
That stage literally means pretty soda when they gutted the place you hammered
and hammered and nails and shit like that.
So fuck you.
I'm calling up,
but you're not going up.
I'll go up last night.
No,
I go,
I'm up.
I'll never play her again.
That's fine.
I haven't played it since.
Wow.
You know,
man,
I,
that's respect.
That's a totally different situation.
And I,
and I totally see your side of it.
I totally do.
And
the girls,
if they really wanted a,
you know,
to do their show and then have you go on last,
have you gone afterwards?
You know,
that's what it asks.
Like,
oh wait,
I don't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Some people don't like that though.
They think that you're going to show them up.
You know,
especially there was 40 people there,
Joe.
It wasn't like if it was sold out,
you know what I mean?
As a matter to them,
those 40 people were there to see them.
And if they know,
if they do mediocre,
you,
they know you're going to crush and you go on after them.
So it's like,
you know,
let,
let me tell you something too.
It's like I'm from that rural,
right,
right.
And I started,
women were fed burns.
Sure.
Yeah.
Back when Fred was running at,
what's a,
Fred died,
he died.
What happened?
Um,
you know,
he,
he had spinal Bifida.
Yeah.
And his parents were still alive and they took him on a cruise,
like a cruise to go to The Bahamas.
I don't know where they went.
And they told Fred one night,
they call Fred,
um,
we'll meet you down here at ate for breakfast.
And Fed Burns goes,
ah,
you know,
and he never showed up to breakfast and they opened up his room and he was dead.
Well,
it's just failure,
failure,
heart failure,
your body failure.
Whenever knows.
I was just awful.
He was an interesting guy.
He got fired Ryan for something.
No,
nothing.
Nothing with the family is crazy man.
I mean fuck,
I got no ill feelings for the store.
I think it's one of the most interesting clubs in the country and I think I
learned a lot doing stand up there.
But the whole point of the whole situation,
the whole point of the home and see an altercation w was supposed to lead to
create a better environment to stop,
you know,
stop someone who is victimizing other comedians and when the club supports that,
you can't support the club anymore.
Yeah.
The club supports that.
It's,
it's not a great,
it wasn't a gray area.
Everybody knew what was going on.
And I know everybody complained for years and years.
So the,
that decision,
the decision they made was like the worst possible decision.
So there's no way I could go back there.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it just sucks the fact that like,
you know,
like bill burr will show up and if Mencias there,
he won't go.
Yeah.
I mean,
those little things,
you know what I mean?
That could fuck up.
I,
you know,
I love the store.
You know,
it's like home.
You could go up right in front of me and see it now.
It doesn't matter.
Now he's toothless.
Now he's just,
it's,
he's got no clause.
It's all,
it's all over.
Did you see the IAM comic?
What'd he said in that movie?
You got to see that,
that will open your mind or your open your eyes.
I just dumped out,
listen,
I just did a benefit with him a month ago.
You know what I mean?
For the police,
the police force.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And you know,
all the longest I've known Carlos,
he had never did drugs or trank as this big thing.
I don't need it.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Natural high right now it's like,
you know,
he's smoking pot.
You know what I mean?
That would probably help him.
Yeah.
Maybe give her a drink.
Drinking.
Yeah.
He's awesome.
He's just,
I can just tell he's sad.
Yeah.
I mean,
well it's coming from a man and as a friend,
victimized,
victimize a friend,
you know,
you watch it and it's,
it's just,
okay.
I was trying to play call of duty with Xbox because I feel bad.
I always send them a friend of mine and he feel bad.
So you want to kill them.
If I go
listen man,
it'd be the positive aspects of working at the store were so true.
I mean,
I know what you say.
I just think you should just do it one night or something.
We,
I'll never be the same again.
How do you know?
Cause it'll never be what it used to be.
What it used to be was a lot of fun.
It was used to be,
we looked,
there was a long time where I was at the store with a store,
felt like it did not have the environment that I envisioned.
I always envisioned it being,
like I said,
comedy Mecca as envision.
There's all these great comics are going to perform there and it's this great
environment.
And then for a long time when I was there and like the early nineties,
you know,
it wasn't like that.
It was,
she was shit.
I said I of went to a it in a sense.
Okay.
Since you left,
it has changed.
Okay.
In this sense.
We're getting a lot more New York guys on the list.
Right?
So you have bill burr,
David off,
you know,
um,
all these New York guys have at that moved here.
Okay.
There Silverman.
Was there the lineups like the other night,
who was it?
Rock and Chappelle.
Did they go up but they showed up,
right?
Yeah.
It's a different New York vibe.
And what I'm saying is this okay?
From two years ago that you were there,
Carlos Carlos is the people who run the club.
I know it's top.
Whoever's running carb is the same people running the club.
I know Tom.
He said some stupid shit to Brian just the other day when he went there and he
called me a fag.
Tommy Tommy's retarded.
He's a,
he's a Ding Dong there dude.
It was always going to be what he is,
you know?
I know there's not this,
it's what us a comedy store is,
is an idea.
Okay.
The idea is that there's this,
this Mecca of comedy where everybody's hanging out and all this crazy be like
debt back porch area,
the back parking lot.
How much fucking fun did we have back there?
So much I've had craziness and hilarity the greatest moments of my life with
them.
Various moments.
Just always,
everybody was doing something funny.
Joey Diaz has got his fucking pants down.
It was crazy.
Always something chaos and then there's always crazy people coming back there
and hanging out with us and then you don't even know how the fuck they are.
And who's this guy's guy's nuts and he thinks he's an angel.
And I talked to us about the cheeses that hangs out there.
I got it.
Geez.
Yeah.
The guy with the cross that walks down down sunset with his fucking cross,
you know the guys looked like Colonel Sanders.
If he seen that guy,
that guy's a crew like Colonel Sanders and Jesus and him together are always the
best combo.
So they're getting an argument.
You're looking at a finding of a house,
the Lord or ticket crazier.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That place is awesome.
You know,
and but the idea of what the comedy story is,
you bring that everywhere with you man.
Everything that everywhere on the road,
I bring that everywhere.
Where I do stand up sounds is a perfect example.
It,
this sells comedy hall has this new place that opened up on Melrose is a guy
from New York.
He had a place on the brayer for awhile,
but they had like a liquor,
liquor license issue and now he reopened a new place.
Fucking guy is great.
He's got open mics like almost every night.
Super supportive of Comedians,
just wants people to come down.
He's always trying to feed you,
give you drinks and he's super consistently nice.
He's really nice guy who loves comedy and he's running,
he's trying to make a good comedy club.
Okay.
And because of that,
comics are flocking to this place.
Diaz does it all the time.
Ari does it.
Brian does it all the time.
Night to night.
His show,
we'll have at least 50,
60 comics wanting to go up at their eight o'clock shut in Ireland.
Yeah.
Do I have to showcase to become a regular thing?
You want to do all of them?
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
You don't have to do anything and they'll just hook you up,
man.
You go me.
He'll give you a door deal.
You can pack the place.
Yeah.
It's super sweet.
That's why I liked it.
Didn't need a new room.
Maybe when you go to the Improv and you go to places like south,
you realize,
okay,
well there's places that don't have this crazy attitude that the place is the
star.
You know,
like Tommy always had this attitude that the store is the star and so did a
member.
Uh,
who's the guy who fucking,
who used to run it before Scott Day.
Remember Scott?
Scott Dale.
Yeah.
Dunkin was the stuff people don't realize this doc Trussell our boy.
It was the,
uh,
the talent manager for the store a year ago and he had to quit because he didn't
want to be on Pauly shore's reality show.
They wanted to put it on the radio show in Paris.
So fuck.
It was like,
I'll read the book with the Improv doesn't have though that the store has,
is that wild west wives?
You're right.
You know what I mean?
No,
because it's like you can't go over the light,
you know what I mean?
There's rules and this and that.
So you can't run across the place in my underwear if I want to write.
You know what I mean?
Right.
But at the store,
there's always still that vibe of like anything can happen.
Right.
So you could miss that,
right?
Yes,
yes.
I do miss that.
But I,
that's everywhere.
To Joey Diaz,
this,
that vibe comes with us.
Hi.
Yeah.
What I'm doing this weekend,
by the way,
Mandalay Bay theater,
it's almost sold out.
You're going to get tickets.
Jump on that shit.
Now.
Um,
there's a,
there's not much left and Mike Houston Friday we will don't totally,
it's Friday night,
uh,
February 4th,
which is the night before the UFC,
so,
and it's at Mandalay Bay,
which is where the UFC,
so it's going to be fucking crazy if you want tickets.
You've got to jump on it now.
And it's Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir.
So it's the,
the full death squad roster and um,
Bobby Lee is going to be at the Houston Improv that weekend.
The same weekend,
February 4th and fifth and sixth Sunday too.
Is it not this weekend,
is it this week?
This weekend coming up the next weekend after that.
Oh,
next weekend.
So what does that 11th something like that.
Yeah,
let's find out exactly what people don't get crazy.
Yeah.
We don't want to,
I came to stay and you dip.
I mean
you are my favorite.
You're a droid.
Could you just turn it on?
Yeah,
just make,
sorry is uh,
are you happy with the drawing and I'll go with that purchase.
Check out this new camera,
12th and 13th.
Bobby Louise Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
And how Ballantine's,
which is Monday.
Oh Bam,
you're doing Valentine's Day in Houston,
which by the way,
I love Houston.
I'm coming back a fucking swear to God.
I know.
I haven't been there in forever.
We're trying to work out a deal.
Uh,
the problem was I don't want to do any shows where people have to stand up.
And I was doing the house of Blues and the House of Blues they wanted,
they wanted,
I think it's like 600 people standing and 600 people see it.
And I'm like,
that's crazy.
Let's,
I did that in Vegas.
I've done in Vegas a bunch of times.
And the problem it becomes,
the bar just becomes filled with people talking.
There's way too many people there and everyone's drunk and no one knows how to
fucking whisper and it becomes chaos.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I went to see one of Doug's Stan hope shows where I had to stand and I was like,
no more standing cause I watched as an member,
I'm like,
this isn't fun.
It hurts your feet.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
yeah.
You get up and shit.
So I had a bunch of deals where I was supposed to do the,
the Houston area,
but every time did we ran into this fucking standing roadblock at theaters.
We ran into it.
So I'm just going to go to the comedy club.
So the Improv,
uh,
we're working it out.
We're going to figure that shit out.
So,
um,
anyway,
one more time.
Friday night,
February 4th,
Mandalay Bay theater,
me,
Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir the next weekend,
the 11th,
12th and the 13th and Valentine's Day,
Bobby Lee will be at the Houston Improv is a,
it's a very nice club to have a new one there.
It's sweet,
right?
So I it just redid it.
We did it.
Yeah.
Shaka lock a motherfucker.
So,
uh,
that's the deal.
And then the weekend after that,
uh,
I'm at the Brayer Improv.
That's the 18th,
19th and 20th.
And we're going to get Brian really high and make them go on stage every night
so he forgets his material.
That's one of my favorite new things.
You got to,
it's trial by fire sign.
You did good this weekend.
He did real good this weekend.
Seven minutes.
You probably fucking killed for four.
You've got a solid four minutes of bits in there.
You're doing all right kid.
They're hustling.
No,
he just goes out.
It goes as it does it guess by throws.
He's fucking getting tossed to the alliance.
So that's the 18th,
19th and 20th is the Bray Improv of February.
And then the weekend after that I'm in fucks.
You can go to Joe Rogan dotnet and read all this shit yourself.
Pitches a this Thursday.
Um,
I'm trying to get Ori and Joey.
I'm not sure if I can,
uh,
if not maybe Brian Cowen or someone else,
but they'll definitely be a show on Thursday.
We're figuring out who the fuck's going to do it.
Um,
but Friday night is the show.
So it'd be nice if we could.
And then Thursday night Ari has a show that I'm going to be on as well at the
Improv.
That's his story.
Tell show great show.
Bobby Lee.
Thank you.
Thank you so much,
Joe podcast.
You're the fucking shit,
my friend for many,
many years and I love you.
I totally fine.
Happy you're here.
Thank you.
To the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link,
enter in the code name Rogan,
and you get 15% off your masturbatory utensil or right bitches.
You know,
I love you.
I'll see you in a couple of days.
All right.
Thanks for all the support for everything.
For everything.
You motherfucker
make life a dream.